Morgen
Moin Leute, was habe ich verpasst? Die Woche war bestimmt einiges los, aber ich habe nichts davon mitgekriegt
Sind wieder irgendwelche Internet-Knotenpunkte ausgefallen, Clouds abgekackt oder sonst was?
Hab ich irgendwas verpasst? Ich glaube es... Was sagst du dazu, dass die Amis Frankfurt aufräumen wollen?
Äh...
Keine Ahnung. Wollen sie? Das US-Army patrouilliert an deutschem Bahnhof
Seit wann hat er eigentlich so kurze Haare?
Keine Ahnung. Ich wusste nicht, dass die Amis am Hauptbahnhof sind in Frankfurt
Aber
Ich meine, wirklich machen können die ja nichts, außer da rumlaufen
Außerdem laufen da bestimmt schon genug rum
Wobei rumpatrouillieren eher nicht. Ah, keine Ahnung
Weiß nicht. Laut, ja?
Leute, ich war heute schon rennen
Ich bin 7 Uhr 15 aufgestanden
7 Uhr 20 so in dem Dreh. Mülli, dankeschön für den Sub
Dann war ich 45 Minuten rennen
So bis... Also ich habe jetzt was gegessen
Bin 7 Uhr 45 bin ich glaube ich raus, dann war ich rennen, dann war ich 8 Uhr 30, ungefähr wieder da
Dann habe ich noch kurz Zeug umgezogen
Bin an den Rechner, hab Rechner angemacht, beide, Streaming-Vorschau-Rechner
Und hab angeworfen, ja
Also ich schaffe jetzt relativ konstant 6 Minuten 30 pro Kilometer, über 6 Kilometer
Meine Standardstrecke ist so 6,07, 6,1, so je nachdem auf welcher Straßenseite ich laufe
Das packe ich relativ konstant jetzt, wobei ich das nicht jedes Mal laufe. Heute, heute hatte ich auch wohl, ich sag's euch, heute hatte ich auch nur
Bin ich extra mal ein bisschen langsamer gerannt
Ich glaube heute hatte ich 7 Minuten 20 oder sowas
Man kann es ja nicht immer total übertreiben, das ist ja auch blöde
Wenn man es immer voll übertreibt
Dann hat man irgendwann keinen Bock mehr
Zu wirklich springen tut es wahrscheinlich auch nichts
Also heute, heute 6,1 Kilometer
Ja, 7 Minuten 39 pro Kilometer heute
Dafür nur 148 Puls im Durchschnitt
Also langsam geht es echt gut, muss ich sagen. Moin, langsam geht es echt gut
Ich glaube das schnellste, was ich je hatte, also das schnellste, was ich bisher hatte, war
Jetzt misst der Zähl irgendwie 6,27 oder so
Für die 6,1 Kilometer, also nicht für die, also pro Kilometer über 6,1 Kilometer
Und da hätte noch ein bisschen, da wäre sicherlich noch ein bisschen was gegangen, aber ich muss ja wieder heimkommen
Bringt ja nichts, wenn ich zwischendrin voll im Arsch bin und nicht mehr zurückkomme
Also was ich unbedingt mal machen muss ist, ich muss mal auf irgendeinen Sportplatz hier
Mit so einer, wie heißt das, mit so einer Bahn drumherum
Und muss mal wirklich
Da kontrolliert mit Pulsgurt und so rennen, dass ich mal weiß, was mein maximaler Puls ist
Ich weiß es immer noch nicht
Also das höchste, was ich mal hatte, war 184
Als ich mal voll die Brücke hochgerannt bin
Nachdem ich schon 2, 3 Kilometer gelaufen bin, aber
Da war ich auch nicht so richtig kaputt
Das müsste man halt mal wegen dem Sportplatz testen, wo es halt genau gerade geht
Gucken
Was das so ist, weil
Ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt zu wissen
Neue Neowim Stable-Version
Nice, Release Neowim
Also soll man gucken
Bam, vor einer Stunde
Ne,
Vor 3 Tagen
Was sagt die Waage
Weiß ich nicht, soll ich mich mal draufstellen?
Chatge, Chatge
Ihr dürft es euch jetzt aussuchen
Soll ich schnell, es dauert 1, 2 Minuten
Soll ich schnell rüber ins Bad rennen und mich draufstellen?
Ich hab keine Ahnung
War da schon eine Weile nicht mehr drauf
Ich kann, ich kann rüber rennen ins Bad
Und keine Ahnung, ich kann nicht mehr draufstellen
Ich kann nicht mehr draufstellen
Ich kann nicht mehr ins Bad und gucken
Soll ich?
Okay, ich bin gleich wieder da
Wieder da
92,55
Allerdings mit T-Shirt, Socken und Hose an
Also wenn man da noch ein bisschen was abzieht
Ich sag einfach mal 92
Ich hab auch schon was gegessen jetzt
Und was getrunken
Also das was ich rausgeschwitzt hab
Hab ich auch wieder aufgefüllt
Also
Ich hatte
Ich hatte letztens
Letztens bin ich
Bin ich mir wirklich zackig gerannt
Hab mich danach
Naggisch auf die Waage gestellt
Da hatte ich 100
Äh, nicht 100
91,
Ich weiß es gar nicht
Ich muss nachgucken
91,78
Oder irgendwie sowas
91,
Ich glaube 91,78
Was gar nicht so übel ist
Natürlich
Wenn ich, wenn du dich danach
Wenn du ordentlich
Liter trinkst und so
Da wächst halt schon mal gleich ein bisschen mehr
Von einem halben Liter trinkst
Was er wieder rausgeschwitzt hat
Also
Ich find das
Ich find das wirklich super nice
Diese App von Garmin
Ich mein
Ey
Keine Ahnung
Wie genau das Ganze ist
Ja
Ja also mir schon
Wie gehts dir, Brionik?
Klingt ein bisschen wie diese
Lego
Lego Dinger
Also ich find
Ich find die App mega nice
Wie genau das ist
Sei mal
Sei mal dahingestellt
Aber
Die zeigt dir
Die zeigt dir wieviel Kalorien
Man verbraucht hat
Also die sagt
Dass ich heute 5
510 verbraucht habe
Mit der Runde
Wobei
Die kann das ja auch nur grob sagen
Wobei ich glaube
Das ist gar nicht mal so
Weit von der Realität weg
Weil die Uhr hat ein GPS drin
Die Uhr weiß
Wie schwer ich bin
Wie schnell ich bin
Und
Erkennt Steigungen
Und sowas
Ich glaube
Die kann das relativ gut ausrechnen
Und was ich auch ganz interessant find
Ist
Die weiß halt
Über die App
Die kennst halt auch
Die Temperatur und sowas
Die sagt
Ich hab 777ml Schweiß verloren
Also Wasser
Ich find das immer ganz interessant
Was da an
Stats drinne stehen
Du hast einen Fehler gemacht
Ja haben wir alle
Ist normal
Du machst permanent Fehler
Und da gibt es halt diese Redensart
So nach dem Motto
Ich weiß nicht wie es geht
Irgendwie
Wenn man
Manche Fehler muss man lernen
Und wenn man 2 mal macht
Ist man blöd
Wobei das auch nicht stimmt
Weil ganz ehrlich
Ganz viele Leute
Machen ganz viele Sachen
Mehr als einmal falsch
Es dauert manchmal ein bisschen
Bis man draus gelernt hat
Geht nicht nur
First try
Und auch nicht
Second try
Manchmal dauert es
Keine Ahnung
Eleven try
Ja
Zum Beispiel
Ganz
Also ganz
Einfaches Beispiel
Das dieses
Man ist
Wenn es total blöd
Wenn man Fehler 2 mal macht
Nicht stimmt ist
Stellt euch mal vor
Immer nachdem ich auf dem Klo war
Den Klo Deckel zu
Und ihr habt vorher
Nie den Klo Deckel zu gemacht
Meint ihr
Ihr kriegt das
First oder second try hin
Im Leben nicht
Ihr braucht da
2 Monate für
Bis ihr euch dran gewöhnt habt
Ich also
Ich spreche da aus Erfahrung
Weil normalerweise
Ich hab nie den Klo Deckel zu
Also
Ich rede jetzt
Nachdem man fertig ist
Dann zumachen
Warum man zumachen sollte
Ganz einfach
Weil meine Katze
Der Meinung ist
Sich auf den Klo Rand
Zu stellen
Und aus dem dreckigen Klo
Zu trinken
Seitdem mache ich
Den Klo Deckel immer zu
Und da habe ich bestimmt
2 Monate gebraucht
Bis ich mich dran gewöhnt habe
Dass ich
Nachdem ich auf dem Klo war
Und fertig bin
Den Klo Deckel wieder zumachen muss
Aber mittlerweile
Habe ich mich dran gewöhnt
Jetzt geht es automatisch
Das dauert aber ein bisschen
Meine Freundin ist wegen
Der Arbeit außerhalb
Und ich bin
In der Zeit
Wo sie nicht da war
Rückfällig geworden
Naja
Kommt drauf an
Wegen was
Abspülen mit offen
Ja
Chat
Ihr habt wieder
Super Gedanken
Chat geht
Jetzt wieder
On Point
So
Lasst uns mal
Lasst uns mal kurz gucken
Was gibt es
Neues
In der Neo-Vim
In der letzten
Neo-Vim Version
Ah
Die
Das ist
Das finde ich cool
Der Codename
Von dem Editor
Ist jetzt
Bram
Oder Bram
Wahrscheinlich
Bram
Spricht man es aus
Das ist der
Originale
Vim Erfinder
Nicht
VI
Help
Uganda
Ja
Der hat
Also
Immer wenn
Vim geöffnet wurde
Ohne Datei
Stand ein
Spenden Hinweis
Drinnen
Für
Kinder in
Uganda
Glaube ich
Deswegen
Help
Uganda
Dabui
Was gibt es
Neues
Irgendwelche
Special
Dinger
Keine Ahnung
Windows Taste
Und Alt Taste
Okay
Ging das noch nicht
So
Okay
Go
So
Back
Okay
Yes
Back
Okay
Extract
Back
Preview
Extract
Не
Edge
Glaube ich zumindest
Was ich jetzt persönlich noch ganz spannend finden würde ist wo ist denn das source code
der source code von der programmiersprache
Hier nicht hier sind nur die examples
Wo ist wo ist die wo ist die implementierung?
Das wird mich tatsächlich noch interessieren source code getting started
Wo ist das source code dazu changelog?
Das ist das nicht open source kann das sein
Ist das okay das ist nicht open source naja gut dann habe ich keinen bock darauf das zu verwenden
Hab schon gedacht hier kann man sich den source code mal angucken
mich nämlich interessieren in was sie implementiert haben und was da sonst noch so drum herum ist weil so
Ich weiß nicht in der aktuellen zeit es gibt eigentlich keinen grund mehr keine open source
Entwicklungs
Technologien mehr zu verwenden das meiste wichtige ist open source es gibt immer noch so ein paar kleine nischen dinger ja zum beispiel wenn man
Irgendwelche geschichten braucht irgendwelche shp geschichten oder was auch immer welche um irgendwelche proprietären sachen anzusprechen
Aber das allermeiste ist mittlerweile open source ja
Von der sprache bis zu vielen language tools bis zu den meisten der wichtigen libraries eigentlich mehr oder weniger alle wichtige
Also im prinzip ist es ist im prinzip egal ja
Auch die compiler implementierung interpreter implementierung
Jit implementier was auch immer run times ist eigentlich mehr oder weniger bei den wichtigsten sachen heute open source egal ob du jetzt sie scharf
anguckst da gut bei sie scharf gibt es bei den entwicklertools die einen oder anderen closed source sachen von microsoft noch aber die braucht man nicht unbedingt
Zumal wenn man rider verwendet was übrigens auch closed source ist
nicht
Java gerade sind sehr viele am schwenken auf open jdk weiß gar nicht ob noch irgendjemand neue projekte mit java enterprise
anfängt open source python schon immer open source ruby
Bash
Sogar c und c++ wobei man da halt sagen muss da gibt es ja keine referenz implementierung in dem sinne wobei bei c weiß ich bei c++ gibt es
keine da gibt es
So ein paar die
Verbreitet sind aber keine offizielle offizielle standard implementierung rast eigentlich so mehr oder weniger alles wichtige
go
Alles alles wichtige ist eigentlich mittlerweile open source inklusive run time sprach sprach
Guides specs tools meistens auch
editor plugins und alles also ich weiß nicht warum ich
Eine sprache die komplett closed source es verwenden sollte du weißt im endeffekt ja nie was es macht
Nicht dass es nicht dass man jetzt dann standardmäßig immer unterstellen müsste die würden irgendwelche komischen sachen treiben aber ich finde immer ein
bisschen problematisch
Sachen einzusetzen wo man gar nicht die chance hat nachzugucken was es macht das geht mir bei windows ja auch immer auf den sack
Bei windows hast du keine ahnung ja bei windows guckst du manchmal hier
Kennt ihr das also mal angenommen ihr macht ihr task manager auf so was jetzt einfach mal hier task manager auf
ihr macht task manager auf
Also ich nehme es mir prozessexplorer war mal da
Hier wo schon wieder da waren so und dann sortieren wir das war
So und wenn man hier durch scrollt kennt ihr das manchmal
Gibt es dann random zu irgendwelche neuen sachen die auf blotten in den windows in den windows ding und was keine ahnung was ist es
Ja zum beispiel das hier das habe ich noch nie gesehen an anzi kap was ist es ich habe keine ahnung
Alles klar anzi kap noch nie gesehen
Ist mir komplett neu dass es gibt da tauchen manchmal irgendwelche random sachen auf was ich was ich übelst kacke finde
Guck mal open console was zum teufel ist open console ah microsoft terminal okay alles klar
Ja obs und so
Tja
Das ist halt richtig dumm
Das mag ich unter linux da weiß ich was läuft und wenn ich nicht weiß was es ist
Oder was ich da was als abhängigkeit installiert wird kann ich immer danach suchen gucken was es ist real agent smith dankeschön für den sub
und
darkseid und vegan nico
Und der agent smith danke für den sub leute
Kannst du mal darauf reagieren
Was
What the fuck
tiktok
Aus prinzip nicht
Schlecht das ist das schönste ok
Gibt es gute postman alternative die sind leider auch keine umsauce und führen jetzt account zwang hat wirklich
Waren die nicht mal open source
Haben die das
Haben die das irgendwie rückgängig gemacht
und
und vor allem
vor allem warum account zwang
Die ist doch open source das ding hier guck
Ach nee oder auch nicht
Ja, keine ahnung ja es gibt gute postman alternativen, aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich bin von postman auch schon komplett weg mittlerweile
benutze die dinger ich benutze die dinger gar nicht also es gibt
Es gibt mittlerweile in wishell studio code selbst eingebaut sowas ich glaube
Wie ging das
Ich glaube man muss eine datei http nennen und dann konnte wishell studio code mittlerweile sogar selbst sowas
Es habe ich noch nie ausprobiert habe ich letztes mal ein tutorial gesehen es gibt aber ich weiß aus dem kopf keins aber es gibt
sich es gibt sich solcher dinger
Es gab ja mal eine zeichnung postwoman weil irgendjemand gedacht hat
Postman dann wirst du aber das wurde umbenannt in irgendwas anderes
Man konnte doch jetzt das ist doch neu ich habe das noch nie ausprobiert man konnte doch irgendwie eine datei keine ahnung
punkt http nennen war das so
Nee das konnte das konnten die doch jetzt eingebaut oder
Ach ich weiß nicht mehr wie das geht ich habe da letztes in einem tutorial drüber gesehen
man kann jetzt
Man kann jetzt irgendwie diese get request und direkt wishell studio code machen keine ahnung ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert
Also so scheint es zumindest schon mal nicht zu gehen
Doch habe ich letztens in einem tutorial gesehen man kann jetzt man kann jetzt http datei nur irgendwie sowas anlegen und direkt reinschreiben
get bla bla bla irgendwie letztens erst tutorial drüber geguckt
Aber wenn das so ein zusätzliches virenprogramm unter windows
Nur standard windows defender
Ich muss mal kurz hier die klimaanlage anmachen ist übelst warm schon
Aber das ist eh nervig
Hier champ v2 schon wieder outdatet habe ich gesehen dass es rausgekommen ist ja
Aber dürfte relativ easy sein zu upgraden
Und das neue theme sieht viel hübscher aus als das alte standard theme das werden wir wahrscheinlich auch benutzen
Aber ich komme ihr aktuell nicht wirklich zu da was zu machen
Ich habe auch letztens wieder in die issues geguckt da gibt es gibt sogar wieder neue
Nee
Nee nee das war es nicht es gab offiziell habe ich habe letzten zu teuer geguckt dass es jetzt irgendwie
Offiziell dass man oder war das in rider
Vielleicht war es auch ein rider und ich bringe es nicht heider
Ach das war ein rider standardmäßig mittlerweile drinne
Dann habe ich dann habe ich das durcheinander gebracht
genau
Man braucht man muss eine datei anlegen punkt http oder punkt rest
Dann kann man direkt da drin
Get requests und post requests und so zeug ausführen was ich eigentlich ganz nice finde
Aber stimmt das ich habe es dann habe ich durcheinander gebracht im kopf dass ich dachte es sind wir es wie es coat
Aber nein es ist anscheinend nur in den jet planes dingern
Aber neben das was irgendjemand hat es doch hat auch gerade hopscotch vorgeschlagen probier mal das aus das ist glaube ich
der
Postman nachbau der ursprünglich mal post woman hieß den sie dann umbenannt haben hopscotch
Finde ich auch ich fand den namen auch bescheuert
So nach dem motto okay es gibt einen post man wir machen jetzt aus prinzip
Post programm was post woman heißt auch keine ahnung man kann man kann es auch übertreiben
Mit mit aufgeweckt sein aber jeder darf natürlich sein open source programm nennen wie er will
Ist ja sein projekt aber hopscotch weiß ich klingt irgendwie griffiger
Das weißt du ja heutzutage manche nehmen das bitte ernst so alles
Ich habe letztens wieder richtig bescheuerte diskussion mitgekriegt da wurde drüber diskutiert
ob ob man baldur skate 3 spielen kann weil angeblich wäre baldur skate 3
Ihr kennt ja das standard zeug was da immer geschrieben wird so nach dem motto nur gemacht um
Irgendwie
Besonders woke zu sein und bla und sonst wie was die steht die leute ich sage alle beide seiten die spinnen komplett
Also bei baldur skate 3 habe ich noch nie was davon gemerkt
Klar du kannst du kannst irgendwie als ja richtig kekalo man du kannst als männlicher
Protagonist quasi dann männliche npcs romanzen wobei das jetzt wirklich nicht neu ist
Ich bin ich bilde mir sogar ein dass man in
Dragon age origin sogar schon ja doch relativ sicher
Wie hieß der tank aus dragon age origin der blonde ich habe vergessen wie
companions
Alistair genau ja den meine ich
Den meine ich den konnte man glaube ich in dragon age auch schon romanzen als als
Male charakter also so neu ist das kam 2009 oder so raus
ja also
Ist jetzt ist jetzt nix nix neues übrigens auch richtig richtig nice das game
Falls noch jemand nicht gespielt hat also ganz ehrlich ich finde
baldur skate 3 ist ein ziemlich gutes
Ziemlich guter nachfolger von dragon age origins vom vom kamera angle her ein bisschen von der grafik her
Passt gut ist es halt nicht
Dragon age ist halt nur intern turn based aber an sich kannst du es realtime mit pause spielen
Also richtig richtig da ist das game
Und da haben sie sich wieder aufgeregt drüber ich weiß nicht was was da heutzutage los ist
Überall wird schon über jeden scheiß und aufgeregt
Hier sind doch bestimmt genug win sec bis der vom jahr auf jeden fall der hälfte des chatters ist win bis sec
voll stack def bis
Der forbes
Welche idee nutzt ihr hauptsächlich für kubernetes helm terraform deployments
visual studio code also ich
Ich mache kubernetes manifest in visual studio code helm jammel zeug in visual studio code und terraform
hcl tf files
In visual studio code das ist auch so ein ding was ich nicht so ganz verstehe
Terraform ist eines der meist verbreiteten produkte so im cloud umfeld aber die wishes zu aber generell die idee der ide support ist richtig
schrott ganz ehrlich richtig schrott
das wischt ich glaube das ist sogar
Ich glaube das ist sogar offizielles terraform plugin vom hersteller kommt mal hier
Das hat absichtlich absicht das aber absichtlich nicht absichtlich vergesst verdient hat es so schlechte so schlechte
Bewertung das ist richtig shit ich habe keine ahnung wie es sein kann dass bei so einem verbreiteten produkt einem so
beliebten und und und viel benutztem produkt
Warum die idee die der editor im ide support bei terraform so ultrascheiße ist anders kann man es nicht sagen
Ich meine die basics funktionieren ja oftmals noch nicht ich würde ganz ehrlich wisst ihr was das mindeste ist was ich erwarte
Von so einer von so einer extension das ist dass es ordentlich die datei formatieren kann
Ich erwarte noch nicht mal großartiges auto complete oder sowas ich erwarte dass wenn es eine terraform extension gibt
Dass du dass du sagst okay ich schreibe jetzt hier irgendwas rein plopp gleich eins ich drücke speichern
Der formatiert die datei und dann ist die richtig formatiert nicht mal das funktioniert manchmal formatiert das einfach gar nicht
Weil irgendwie keine ahnung der lässt sich nicht so gut
Gar nicht weil irgendwie keine ahnung der language server abgekackt ist oder das plugin kacke ist die intellisens geht regelmäßig kaputt
Die geht dann einfach nicht dann sagst du dann local punkt und wunderst dich warum nichts kommt
Ich erst wirklich ist es mir unerklärlich wie man von so einem verbreiteten
Beliebten ja an sich ja auch guten produkt eine so beschissene
Entwicklungsplattform bieten kann wie das herrschi kommt mit diesem wie das code plugin ist es mir komplett unbegreiflich keine ahnung ich bin mir nicht sicher
Ob es da vielleicht
Gibt es da vielleicht für jetbrains irgendwas besseres
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht oder
Das ist richtig richtiger schrott
Das verstehe ich nicht keine ahnung warum das so kacke ist ja und ja ganz ehrlich die
Das hell plugin ist auch kacke
Da kannst du autocomplete und sowas auch auch komplett vergessen glaube ich glaube das hellen plugin
macht einen kompletten abgang
Wenn du mehr als eine ressource irgendwie profil anlegen willst dann geht's autocomplete nicht richtig dann gehen nur noch die hellen autocomplete
Sachen aber die kubernetes autocomplete sachen sind dann kaputt und sowas ganz ganz furchtbar wir ich verstehe es ehrlich gesagt
Ich kann das nicht verstehen man muss ja sagen in das hier und gerade auch in kombination
Dürfte so eines der meistverwendeten sachen in der cloud sein ich weiß nicht warum die wie sagt man so schön entwickler experience so kottenschlecht ist
Und selbst kubernetes manifest anlegen in visual studio code ist nicht so dolle
Aber das geht noch aber sobald man das in helm anlegen will ist komplett unusable
Ich verstehe es nicht ich verstehe auch nicht warum da nicht mal irgendeiner hingeht und
Sagen wir mal wenn es halt als visual studio code plugin nicht nicht hinbekommt
Dann da irgendwie den
Einen editor verbaut oder sowas ich oder warum jetbrains sich um die idee kommt mit der cloud native ide oder sowas
Weil das ist wirklich abartig
Also ich verwende auch wie das code aber man kann es nicht richtig das ist wirklich schrottig ja richtig richtiger müll
Am besten ist am besten ist tatsächlich
immer immer zweite
Ja das das auch das auch
Am besten ist echt immer terminal aufhaben und alle zehn sekunden mal ausführen und gucken ob alles noch funktioniert
Also ich habe ich habe vor jedem commit was ich mache
Ins in was terraform angeht
Habe ich ein tf lindt ein tf format davor in der cli
Weil man sich nicht darauf verlassen kann dass das format richtig funktioniert
Und terraform ja der meinung ist manche sachen sind erlaubt und manche nicht das ist das ist eh weird champ ich ja
Es ist es ist es ist extrem weird also zum beispiel darfst du in terraform darfst du sowas hier machen
Tut mir mal tun wir mal so als wäre das wäre das terraform ja also was zu machen darfst du irgendwie so eine inline funktion
so zack zack
So also sowas
Sowas darfst du machen in terraform zum beispiel ja da kommt dann ein string raus wo diese variable an der stelle eingesetzt wird
Was du in terraform nicht machen darfst ist sowas
ohne eine warnung zu bekommen
Und wer sich jetzt fragt warum ich habe keine ahnung
Hier sagen sie online empty string interpolation soll man nicht benutzen
das problem ist nur
Wenn das hier in den ind ist
Dann könnte man zwar da könnte man zwar so schreiben aber dann bleibt es ein ind das heißt ich müsste dann sowas machen
So und jetzt ganz ehrlich
Ich weiß nicht was besser ist
Also ich persönlich bin der meinung dass hier
chat was meint ihr
Was was ist so ein taktisch schöner
Wenn ich wenn das hier in den ind ist lol ist ein ind ja ind lol gleich 1 ist zwar nicht terraform aber ihr wisst
So ich will ich will dass hier als als in den string rauskommt am ende ja
Also ganz ehrlich ich finde das hier einfach angenehmer zumal man normalerweise string interpolation ja so auch macht aber warum ist das
Deprecated ich verstehe es nicht
Das ist hässlich wie die nacht alter ich weiß nicht was ich die leute ausgedacht haben wieder
Ja
Ich verstehe ich ganz ehrlich keine ahnung ich hasse terraform richtig mittlerweile
Und hell mag ich auch nicht weil weil die go template sündags richtige abfahrt ist für terraform ist übelste rotz
Die anderen sachen sind aber auch nicht so viel geil
Das kommt ja noch dabei
Terraform ist ja noch eigentlich das beste allein schon durch das durch die riesen menge an module und verbreitung die es gibt
Ich finde ja vom ansatz her polumi ganz nice aber das ist nicht so verbreitet und bringt ja auch nix
Wenn man das als einziger verwendet
Relativ regelmäßig es ist nicht so dass ich jetzt jeden tag daran rum baue
Value files editiert jeden tag helmschatz selbst
Relativ unregelmäßig aber kommt doch oft oft genug vor
Das letzte helmschatz was ich gebaut habe ist eins um
Ich überlege gerade was war das erigon erigon ist das
ethereum
Ja
ist um eine ethereum blockchain
gedöhnt in kubernetes zu deployen
Da braucht man da braucht man zwei sachen da braucht man
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen ich habe schon wieder vergessen brauchst zwei sachen du brauchst irgendwie den den
Transaction layer und den den ach keine blockchain zeug fragt mich nicht ich mache zwar seit monaten in so einem blockchain projekt mit aber
Blockchain selbst kann ich mir die hälfte nicht merken ist mir auch vollkommen egal interessiert mich auch gar nicht ja das war das letzte ich gebaut habe
Um ethereum blockchain sachen in kubernetes deployen zu können ich will ja gucken was auf github trendet
preko mit hook
Bietet sich an ja
nicht verkehrt
Wenn man leute hat die in der lage sind geht auf das cli zu verwenden
Wisst ihr wisst ihr einen nachteil von github github und solche sachen ist
Selfmade is dankeschön dass die alle keine githubs mehr unterstützen
Jemand hat auch geschrieben hat es eben hier haben wir im preko mit druck drinnen also preko mit ist ja lokal im github repo
Aber es gibt so was wie pre-receive bei github als hook das war äußerst praktisch da konnte man wenn jemand in das zentrale
Repo oder was ist zentral wirklich zentral ist aber geht kein repo aber das worauf man sich geeinigt hat das von dort alle pullen und pushen
Da konnte man früher sowas wie einen pre-receive hook reinhauen und
Sobald das der pre-receive hook irgendeinen fehler festgestellt hat konnte es zu den kompletten push ablehnen das geht jetzt nicht mehr
Weil das alles asynchron passiert in github und github
Kannst du nicht kannst keine ganz keine githubs mehr machen du kannst natürlich irgendwelche jobs automatisch triggern aber bringt ja nichts
Dann ist es schon gepusht
das wird dadurch ein bisschen auf
Aufgeweicht dass du auf github einfach sagen kannst du musst ein pullrequest machen also ist es egal
Aber trotzdem ich finde es ein bisschen doof dass du keine
richtigen
Ja, bitbucket kann das ich weiß aber nur mit java da brauchst du irgendeinen java hook, das ist auch für den arsch
Oder du musst aufs filesystem gehen
Etwas etwas blöd ja ich fände ich fände es wirklich nice würde github und github noch richtig echte
pre-receive hooks anbieten
So ich wollte mir angucken was trendet da habe ich immer noch nicht gecheckt was es eigentlich ist
Ich habe ich ich habe es mir letztens schon angeguckt aber keine ahnung was das sein sollte
Es ist im prinzip doch einfach nur ein dashboard oder
Ach nee das ist eine linux distribution mit vorinstalliertem
nextcloud und home assistant oder sowas
wen juckt
Bann da gucken wir uns gleich ein fireship video dazu an
incredible fast javascript runtime
Ritten in sick nicht in rast
Deswegen ist es auch nicht blazingly fast sondern incredibly fast weil weil
Blazingly fast dürfen nur rastprogramme sein was ist das ist das sowas wie chef
nur für windows
Ja anscheinend kann man auch im browser benutzen einfach
Jq trendet wie kommt denn das auf einmal beste
Reaktion extrem viel mehr das ist irgendwas für 3d drucker
Ist ja manchmal fände ich es echt gut wenn die leute in ihrer readme schreiben würden was es eigentlich ist
Jetzt jetzt mal ernst leute ich habe meine ernst gemeinte frage für euch wenn ihr diesen text hier lesen würdet ja
The dom amongst the flipper 0 firmware give your flipper the power and freedom it is
Würdet ihr daran denken dass das hier und sich um firmware für einen 3d drucker handelt
Oder bringe ich das durcheinander ist das überhaupt nicht für ein 3d drucker
Das kann sogar sein dass ich verkehrt liege hieß ach nee der hieß klipper oder
Ach moment moment moment moment
Klipper ist die 3d drucker
firmware
Flipper ist dieses wlan hacking device. Ah, das ist jetzt jetzt bin ich durcheinander gekommen
Es hat auch recht ähnliche namen
ja
Flipper wifi das ist dieses orange
orange weiße ding
Blazingly fast written in rust power toys
und fie
eine library zum investment für
Was
AI
Geh weg
So wirklich so wirklich spannend finde ich jetzt eigentlich nur das
Aber solange das nicht open source ist weiß ich nicht ob ich benutzen soll. Das habe ich hier offen. Achso meine meine schuhe
Ich glaube nicht dass wir es überstanden haben
Es ist immer noch die hälfte AI und wer weiß
Das das gibt das jetzt ein bisschen ab und sobald keine ahnung gpt 45 oder sowas um die ecke kommt
gibt es eigentlich schon pläne für
Es gibt nur ei generierte seiten die über ei sachen spekulieren auch da ist
weißt du was die richtige seuche ist auf reddit
Chat gpt antworten
Es gibt so viele chat gpt bots mittlerweile auf reddit die können sie gar nicht alle bannen
Man erkennt das man erkennt das aber meistens meistens erkennt man es weil die antworten so
So völlig sind
wisst ihr die normale reddit antwort ist so nach dem motto es geht eine auf reddit
und sagt
Wenn ich aufs klo gehe ist mein haufen so schwer dass der klo ihn nicht weg spülen kann so was soll ich tun geht
So die normale reddit antwort ist halt irgendwie so ein einsatz was richtig dummes
Vielleicht zwei sätze ein bisschen was hilfreiches und sobald er da eine antwort kommt die irgendwie
zehn sätze enthält
Und nur wage auf das eigentliche problem eingeht dann weißt du immer auch die antwort
Und
Merken dass merken dass die anwender die bei den ticket aufmachen ich kann mich nicht mehr daran erinnern ich hatte ich habe letztens was
gegoogelt als
weil das gedrehe gespielt habe
habe ich irgendwas gegoogelt was halt überhaupt nicht ob wir es in dem game ist
Genau ich weiß wieder was ich gegoogelt habe
Und zwar ich wollte gucken ob es in baldur's gate noch einen ring of protection gibt
außerhalb von dieser einen quest
Weil eigentlich ist so im dnd setting ring of protection oder 0815 ring den es in jeder ecke gibt
Guck doch mal ob es irgendwie außerhalb von dieser quest noch einen ring of protection gibt
So und da habe ich gesucht habe einen reddit post gefunden
Und irgendwie die zweite antwort auf diesem reddit post war sehr sicher chat gpt
Ist überhaupt nicht darauf eingegangen
Sondern nur so diese standard chat gpt
Geschichte so ja als ich als ich baldur's gate 3
Gespielt habe habe ich selbst nach einem ring of protection gesucht, also ich übersetze euch das so irgendwie singengemischt
Habe ich selbst nach einem ring of protection gesucht leider konnte ich auch
Beim durchspielen bis zu act 3 keinen weiteren ring of protection
Finden deshalb vermute ich es befindet sich in diesem spiel von den programmierern eingebaut kein weiterer ring of protection
Und habe ich gesagt was zum teufel keine sau schreibt so das muss eine chat gpt antwort sein und wenn ihr mal genau guckt
Ganz viele reddit posts sind einfach chat gpt und ich verstehe den sinn davon nicht was hat man davon einen reddit bot
Mit chat gpt laufen zu lassen denn man also wenn wenn die ja wenigstens
Spammen würden so nach dem motto die antwort findest du hier und dann kommst du auf einer virenverseuchten seite raus oder auf irgendeiner
bescheuerten
Cashgrab seite von von irgendwas oder einfach nur werbe da würde ich es ja noch verstehen aber einfach nur text antworten zu generieren
Da hat ja niemand was von außer dass irgendjemand diesen bot laufen lassen muss
Also ich verstehe den sinn wirklich nicht also sowohl für die leute die antwort bekommen von dem chat gpt bot auf reddit als auch
für die leute die
gibt leute die kaufen reddit du meinst die fahren da irgendwie karma
Und und wenn sie dann aber damit kriegst du nicht mal karma großartig das dauert ewig
Vielleicht macht es die menge die machen einfach die machen einfach 800 accounts
Und und spammen dann rum und irgendwann haben sie danach im jahr mal ein account mit ein bisschen
Ich habe keine ahnung
Ich weiß noch nicht wo man reddit karma punkte sieht ehrlich gesagt
Lass mich mal kurz gucken auf reddit ich gehe mal kurz auf reddit
Okay
My profile ich habe einen karma punkt
Extremly nice
Aber ich schreibe ja auf reddit nicht ich lese ja nur auf reddit ein reddit post geschrieben bisher all den jahren
Ich weiß nicht
Ich weiß nicht ob ich ein reddit post finde hier reddit
Ja hier das das meine ich das ist auch eine chat leute seriously das ist doch eine chat gpt antwort hier passt mal auf also
der typ will wissen
Gibt es noch weitere ring of protections in bylaws g3 außer von dieser einen quest so lest euch diese antwort mal durch
Das ist doch das ist doch chat gpt oder
All i can say for certain is that the ring is so rare it's not even on the wiki for bylaws g3
My multiplayer group acquired and bla bla bla been able to confirm where it came from till now
That been said the only one is like this is not a chat gpt antwort es kann man doch keiner sagen dass so auf reddit antwortet
Er doch nicht dadurch nicht umsonst minus minus 14 14 dinger das ist so eine typische random sinnlos chat gpt antwort
That being said it may be only one of its likeness in the war in the whole game
Given no one seems to have a clue. Das ist so typisch. Das ist ein typischer chat gpt satz niemand schreibt so
Niemand schreibt so schon gar nicht auf reddit
Okay, der will seine
Der will der will seine seine website verkaufen
Das verstehe ich auch warum das ein bot ist der will seine website verkaufen
Also nicht seine webseite der will der will solche was seine webseite leute auf die webseite locken verstehe
weißt du
Niemand schreibt so auf reddit. Das ist ein bot
Also leute die auf tiktok sind die schreiben nicht so
Ich kann ich kann euch nicht aus eigener erfahrung sagen wie man schreibt nachdem man auf tiktok war ich bin selten auf tiktok
Aber nicht so
Ich würde eher sagen dass ein tiktok zuschauer sowas macht so der der schreibt dann irgendwie
Halt's maul du und dann ist er ab dann ist er abgelenkt und schreibt den post nie fertig
So stelle ich mir tiktok zuschauer vor der fängt den post an mit irgendeiner beleidigung so halt's maul du kackspast oder sowas mit einem
Satz mit einem satz ist er abgelenkt und kehrt nie wieder zu dem post zurück und postet ihn gar nicht
stellte nur 15 tiktok user vor
Haben wir dann hier ein stb
Achso das war das ccc
ccc talk dass der dass der bahn navigator
Spied das war mal schauen
Ja auf twitch gibt es auch bots und wisst ihr was es schon ewig gibt diese twitter bots
Diese twitter bots wo irgendwelche
weiber
Halb nackig drauf sind in profilbild und und wenn du dann drüber hafast über dem bild steht dann im profil in diesem
mini profil vorschau
I want sex free
Follow my profile
Die liken dann irgendwelche irgendwelche posts von vor drei jahren oder so dass sie in der timeline aufploppen da weißt du halt sofort
okay nice scam
Bann blog tschüss
Das bekommst du auf twitter bekommst du das laufend
Solche solche sexy girl spam bots ja bx es ist ja kein
xxx bots auf x
Schon tiny go für arduino ausprobiert ne geht es auf dem esp 32
Kein i2c dann kann ich es nicht richtig
Kein wifi ja okay dann ist ja unsinnig das bringt mir nix no pass
Ich bin jetzt in balos gelten akt 3
Hab schon über 100 stunden in dem game ich mache aber auch jede quest die ich finde finden kann
Ich glaube ich brauche noch mal 50 stunden oder so je nachdem wie lang akt 3 ist
Bis ich da durch bin wobei was man so hört ist ja akt 3 ist wohl noch ziemlich verpackt an vielen stellen und auch
im vergleich zu den zwei akten davor etwas
content und
optionsärmer
Aber larian hat ja wohl schon gesagt sie sie wollen jetzt nach dem riesen erfolg da weiter daran arbeiten also sprich
Wahrscheinlich ist es dann so wie bei divinity original sin 1 und 2 das ist dann irgendwie nach einem jahr so eine sonne
Wie ist das
Wie ist die wie ist das so special edition oder so gibt da gab es auch so eine definitive edition definitive edition
Ja aber die wollen tatsächlich ja auch noch mehr content und story branches und so einbauen die machen definitive edition gehe ich ganz stark von aus
Ja ja ganz ganz original sin 2 hatte auch das ding dass der letzte akt nicht sogar auch auch dings auch
Oldschool sin 1 hatte dass das der letzte akt nicht so geil war das doch ein eis wie machst du das
Du hast dann irgendwie von von dem hersteller so ein gerät was das machen kann mit einem relay und das löst du dann mit dem
shelly aus oder oder wie
Also so ähnlich umgedreht habe ich das bei mir auch
ich habe
von
Ich habe ganz vergessen von wo sind mal von
Keine ahnung von was meine rauchmelder sind irgendwie so ein rotes rotes logo
gibt es dafür für
Was gibt es da hersteller
Ich habe
Ergibt das sinn dass ich zuerst divinity 2 und dann divinity 1 sorge du musst auf jeden fall divinity original sin spielen weil
Divinity gibt es auch als game aber du meinst wahrscheinlich original sin
Die games haben nicht so viel miteinander zu tun
Ich würde tatsächlich 1 zuerst spielen und dann 2
Weil vom gameplay her und insgesamt ist ist ist divinity 2 viel viel ausgereifter
Ich könnte mir vorstellen du hast wenig bock das einser zu spielen noch
Wenn du das zweier gespielt hast ich fand das einser auch extrem gut für die zeit
Aber
Ich weiß nicht ob ich einser noch mal bock hätte nach dem zweier
Ich weiß
Ich weiß nicht wo meine hersteller wir haben uns das ja irgendwann mal im stream sogar angeguckt ich habe so einen ich habe so
einen gerät vom vom rauchmelder hersteller
Das schaltet einen relay also das musste alles musste pären mit den feuer meldern
Und es hat die feuer melde auch miteinander verbunden dass wenn der eine unten in der küche auslöst auslöst dann geht auch geht auch
mein meiner oben an
Für anderen seite ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob ich das wirklich
So lassen soll ich habe das jetzt seit ein paar jahren ich weiß nicht ob so eine gute idee ist weil man hört es
Ja auch so und wenn die alle angehen dann weißt du ja gar nicht wo es genau her kommt man sieht es der blinkt glaube ich
sogar oder aber trotzdem zumindest ich habe da so ein gerät gepaert vom hersteller
und
das habe ich gepaert
mit
Den rauch meldern und dann löst es so einen relay aus wenn wenn es rauch melder gibt
Wenn es rauch rauch gemeldet wird und das bekomme ich dann in home assistant mit und schickt mir eine push notification aufs handy
Stimmt den stream hast du gesehen ja wenn du den stream gesehen hast dann können wir doch mal hier rauch melder suchen
habe ich den stream gelöscht leute weil man den
Ach das ist der stream wo ich den halben stream kacken musste weil ich dünnschiss hatte
Den habe ich gelöscht ich wollte kein
Kein ich sitze auf dem klo streamen und bin die hälfte des streams nicht da machen
Nochmal warte ich setze mich noch mal
Ja das ist das ist dieses teil hier genau hier das löst dann aus und
Stream habe ich anscheinend gelöscht
Ich würde dir die gleichen rauch melder empfehlen die ich auch habe ich weiß leid an elv heißen die elv rauch jetzt mir gerade wieder eingefallen rauch melder
Ja also ich habe von denen
eine kombination aus
Jetzt wüsste wie der mist heißt
Das hier ist nicht hier ist das elv
Warte mal warte mal das sind die nicht glaube ich
Die sehen anders aus kann doch nicht sein dass ich vergessen habe wie meine rauch
Okay zehn jahres rauch melder so viele hersteller gibt es doch davon wahrscheinlich nicht
Ach du scheiß es gibt 30 milliarden
Okay ich muss in die app gucken vom handy da habe ich das drinne ich will jetzt wissen wie man rauch melder heißt man es kann
nicht sein
amazon
auch
melder
Heißen die
Jawohl
Diesen krempel so die habe ich am start
so und dazu habe ich in
kombination
Rf klingt gut ich ich weiß gar nicht was der unterschied zwischen iw und
if ist
so und dafür braucht man
Wenn ich gucke noch mal bei amazon da kann ich das nämlich genau sagen rf ja
So und da braucht man noch ein
I
413 lohnt sich dafür keine ahnung genau
Guck mal wie glücklich er ist nur weil er weil er rauch melder hat genau da gibt es dieses ding hier zu kaufen
Das perst du ganz normal wie ein weiterer rauch melder
Und sie haben natürlich wieder mal kein
Gescheites ein gescheites bild
ein anschaltplan
Ja genau so sieht das aus in drinnen das ding perst du mit einem der rauch melder ja zum beispiel mit
Dem da
Das ist ein rauch melder da kriegst du so ein funk modul dabei was angeblich zehn jahre hält naja mal gucken
Bin mal gespannt weiß ich nicht wie lange das bis jetzt bis jetzt hält ja
Die perst du miteinander und perst die mit dem
Mit diesem koppel modul und so wie ich das gemacht habe ist du kannst also dass das
Genau hier hier musste netzteil ein ganz normales
12 volt dc netzteil anschließen kannst du irgendwie für fünf euro bei amazon kaufen
Netzteil anschließen braucht man nicht braucht man nicht
Das braucht man nur wenn man es manuell auslösen möchte zum alarm testen oder sowas
Was was wichtig ist du willst störung und feueralarm an klemmen
also hier
An klemmen an beispielsweise ein schalli oder einen esp32 oder was auch immer irgendwo wo du kontakte
erkennen kannst
Und ja so habe ich das aktuell also ich habe ich habe hier in das gehäuse habe ich den esp32 eingebaut hier sie sieht ja das
Erzählte ja das case
Esp32 eingebaut ich habe feueralarm angeschlossen und die störung angeschlossen
Der esp32 hängt im wlan
Und wenn der rauch melder auslöst die sind ja gekoppelt mit dem ding dann schaltet das schaltet das relay hier
Und das bekommt man dann auch mit dem esp32
Dann schaltet das schaltet das relay hier und das bekommt der esp32 mit und dann bekommt es mein home assistant mit und wenn es mein home assistant mitbekommt
Dann bekomme ich eine push notification dass das feueralarm gab und die haben aber anscheinend auch was neues sehe ich hier gerade
Ja mein i56 iw da muss ich mal gucken ob was was an dem was an dem vielleicht
besser ist
Weil die dinger kannst du wegschmeißen also das nicht aber die dinger kannst du halt wegschmeißen wenn die batterie alles nach zehn jahren
Was nicht so wild ist man alle zehn jahre mal ein paar neue
vier neue kaufen ist ja nicht das ding
So was haben wir hier 631 hatte ich da
Also musste halt ein bisschen basteln die dinger funktionieren komplett bastelfrei untereinander
Vernetzt wenn du selbst die sachen abgreifen willst musst du ja dieses koppelmodul holen und entweder halt das offizielle von denen
tool auslese smartphone ding anschließen oder halt selbst bauen mit dem esp32
Auch gibt es eine neue season
Die nächste generation der ver also die über die übertreiben es ja auch schon ein bisschen oder
Das trauer spiel ist vorbei
Ist endlich richtig auf kurs
Gäbe es da was mit euch los
Das war danke für den sub oder max gibt es eine neue season oder warum willst du spielen ich würde ja auf nc
Haben die glaube ich nicht oder hat er auch co2 drinne
Was kann was kann er denn alles
Jeder kann der kann nur rauch
Ja, aber ich habe keinen melder bringt ja nix wenn die boxen ausgang hat
okay
Okay
nice
So da lasst uns doch mal schauen was können wir uns dann angucken
fahrrad geklaut ja perfekt das guckt man sich dann ich habe
Fahrrad geladen finde ich es mit einem airtag nun ja
Airtags sind nicht so sonderlich geil um solche sachen nachzuverfolgen aber
Airtags sind sicherlich besser als nichts
Problem bei airtags ist halt die können von alleine nicht funken weit genug
So dass du sie findest da muss halt zufälligerweise einer mit dem iphone in der nähe sein
An flughäfen und sonst wo kommt es dann auch relativ häufig vor aber ja
Muss nicht unbedingt also ich glaube man findet damit aber nicht wirklich realtime und auch jetzt nicht sonderlich
Sonderlich gut mit pech gar nicht ich glaube da gibt es bessere sachen um sein fahrrad zu tracken
Aber sicherlich besser als nix
Ich glaube es ist brauchbar
Aber das war das war es dann das war es dann auch übrigens eine sache muss ich gerade noch mal sagen weil ich kann von
Baldur's Gate 3 hatte ich bin jetzt ja quasi so
erste erste hälfte vom
Dritten akt also eine sache passt nicht das finde ich passt aber das ist jetzt kein problem wirklich von baldur's gate das ist so ein problem von
Generell von vielen rpgs und zwar
Die companions an sich muss man sagen ist sehr viel mühe reingeflossen in baldur's gate 3
Ich mag alle eigentlich außer
Astarion mit dem spiel ich nicht der steht einfach nur bei mir im lager rum und der juckt mich nicht aber
Alle alle anderen werden mit denen wir zumindest regelmäßig gesprochen und ich hatte ich hatte auch
weil sie insgesamt schon
Fünf fünf in der party von acht oder so was es gibt
Also passt so aber was halt gar nicht oder bei den meisten ich passe was viele rpgs nicht hinbekommen
ist eine
Passende
Background also ein passend ein paar eine passende
History von von den companions weil ich versuche mal zu erklären was ich meine ist keine spoiler
Das erfährt man alles innerhalb der ersten paar stunden in akt 1
Und zwar nur mal so als beispiel immer mal karl
Die war
Quasi wenn man jetzt die in die lohr nicht so nicht so kennt die war quasi in der hölle und hat dort für einen
Für eine quasi göttin gekämpft in der in der schlag in verschiedenen
schlachten so und war dort richtig berühmt und bekannt als eine der besten
Teufel die mensch lehrer überhaupt
Und dann fragt man sich so die ist level 1
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Niemand mit level 1 geht dahin
Und metzelt alles weg
Es ergibt keinen sinn dass die level 1 ist mit dem background
so
lias l ist ähnlich so eines der krassesten
kriegerinnen die die zu bieten haben und
Irgendwie nachfrage fahre von irgendeiner königin und sonst war es aber
leifleins
auf die reihe
Shadow hat shadow hat ist ähnlicher ähnlicher background so übelst lang trainiert als scharklerik
Super advance da in diesem in diesem klerik orden und auf geheime mission geschickt und alles
Level 1 weil aber bei shadow hat ergibt es noch irgendwie sinn weil ja standardmäßig
Gedächtnisverlust und alles aber dass dieses problem haben viele
RPGs in den kompanien backstories die müssen aus gameplay gründen level 1 sein
Aber von der von der geschichte her passt es überhaupt nicht dass die level 1 sind
Versteht man was ich meine also ich finde die einzigen zwei wo das wirklich gut passt ist geil
Geil ist zwar history ist zwar background geschichten technisch
Übelst krasser wizard aber
Durch sein missgeschick nennen wir es mal so
Hat er ja so ein bisschen seine macht verloren zumindest kann man das rein interpretieren bei dem ergibt das sinn dass der wieder level 1
ist und bei will
Bei will er gibt es eigentlich auf den ersten blick gar keinen sinn weil will ja übelst bekannter quasi
Nicht nicht söldner aber hält quasi ist an der schwertküste den alle kennen und und so was
Aber bei will macht es insofern doch sinn weil er da viel einbildung dabei ist weil eigentlich kennt ja will niemand
Der tut immer so als ist er der übelst krasse hält und jeder kennt ihn aber eigentlich kennt ihn keiner
Und da ergibt es auch irgendwie sinn von der background story dass der level 1 ist
Aber bei hell sind ergibt es auch kein bock kein sinn dass der level 1 ist
Übelst krasser erzruide mega mega gut bekannt level 1
So dinge ja ich verstehe warum man es aus gameplay gründen macht
Aber background story technisch passt es einfach nicht
Bei astarion keine ahnung mit dem spiel nicht das ist richtig in balos g2 erhält sich die
Technik in balos g2 hat es deutlich besser hingehauen
Weil man damit level
8 oder so glaube ich anfängt weil es gar nicht mehr klappt so um die level 8 fängt man da sie macht
fängt man damit an
hat
Vielleicht vielleicht auch immer sein schei importiert
In den du startest nicht mit level 5 du startest relativ sicher im balos g8 mit level 7 oder 8
Balos g2 starting level
89.000 experience ja das kommt da damals auch noch ein bisschen auf die klasse an
Ja new game stars charakter level 8 korrekt 7 oder 8
Es kommt ein bisschen auf die klasse an ja es war es war in den alten games war es noch je nach klasse ein bisschen unterschiedlich
wann man wie level up hatte
Gibt es leute in
2021 die keine iphone haben ja der überwiegende teil der menschheit hat keine iphone ich glaube es haben nur 25 prozent aller smartphone besitzern
ein iphone der rest hat irgendwas anderes hauptsächlich android
iphone versus android
Verbreitung gucken wir mal guck mal
guck dir mal hier
Ios ist ziemlich ziemlich angezogen die letzten jahre über
Mal hier
sind nur noch 70 30 ziemlich ziemlich gut eigentlich
Aber ist auch irgendwie verständlich ich habe ja ich habe ja android auf auf tablets
Und gefühlt sieht das jede zweite android version komplett anders aus und hat sich
180 grad gewandelt weiß ich ob das immer noch so krass ist wie früher
Ich glaube ich habe kein gerät mit top aktuelle android version
nur zu team team ox ja mache ich aber das schreibt man ohne
Oder ist das was was ich nicht kenne
Ja sind sie auch
Deswegen habe ich auch nur low budget geräte die ich nicht täglich verwende sondern
beispielsweise als
dasport an der wand hängen habe ja verwende ich allerdings immer weniger weil man terminal mittlerweile solche
Splitting sachen und sowas eingebaut hat
Wir können theoretisch nachher eine runde ballos g3 weiterspielen ja aber ich bin halt mittlerweile schon akt 3
ist sagen viele ios besitzer auch
Also wo ich es erlebt habe ist auf dem allerersten iphone se hatte ich an meiner mutter eins gekauft damals und das war wirklich
langsam
Keine zeit für vier champ. Ich habe auch keinen bock gerade
bin zu
zu
Paul
Okay, gucken wir uns mal das video an fahrrad fahrrad verfolgen mit airtex
alle tickets klausen projekt archivieren easy
Also fahrrad geklaut finde ich es mit airtex let's go
das werde ich mir von meinem 3003 kollegen lukas klauen
Er sagt mir nicht wo er es versteckt guck mal hier das ist mein fahrrad das werde ich mir von meinem
3003 kollegen das video ist kacke und wenn chandler das sagt
Er sagt mir nicht wo er es versteckt aber ich werde trotzdem versuchen das wieder zu finden weil ich anders raten nämlich ein apple airtex
Ein billig airtex von aldi ein samsung smart tech und ein teil drauf geklebt habe das
Am besten wäre halt irgendein gps tracker
Mit batterie das sich automatisch auflädt wobei das wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen zu auffällig ist das merkt wahrscheinlich jeder
Also gps tracker heißt ja du kannst ja über gps niemand tracken
das heißt es ist ein gps empfänger
und irgendwie
Iot simkarte oder sowas mit drinnen zum senden
Das ist auch so ein ding was ich immer richtig cringe in irgendwelchen
Filmen finde so nach dem motto ein gps tracker wir tracken ihn über gps nein ihr trackt niemand über gps
gps is read only
Das sind solche bluetooth findehelfer die man mit dem smartphone
Anpicken kann und die dann piepsen und dann kann man zum beispiel das schlüsselbund finden das sich hinter dem sofa versteckt hat all diese findehelfer
Lassen sich aber nicht ich habe das letztens tatsächlich benutzt sowas ähnliches und zwar ich habe mein handy nicht gefunden
Oder habe ich an meiner uhr die ja per bluetooth gepaart ist mit dem handy an meiner uhr kann man auswählen
Handy vergessen und dann dann macht das handy geräusche
Ausgewählt handy vergessen ich habe es erst ich habe es erst nicht gehört wo ist das wo ist das wo ist das
Und irgendwann habe ich es gefunden das lag im wohnzimmer
Zwischen
also zwischen dem sofa und einem polster
Das ist da rein gerutscht und zwar hätten wir es auch gedämmert warum ich bin ich bin vormittags eine runde gerannt
Dort da bin ich hoch ins wohnzimmer habe das handy neben mich auf sofa gelegt und habe ein paar ideen übungen durchgeführt
Und anscheinend ist das handy dann halt die sofa ritze gerutscht
Aber es hat funktioniert also es ist sehr praktisch gewesen mit der uhr das
Zu triggern man ich hätte übrigens genauso gut ein zweites gerät gehen können und sagen wie
ein iphone
Den übungen nicht auf dem sofa vom sofa
Verwenden wenn man selbst in der nähe ist also wenn das eigene smartphone
Verbindung über bluetooth oder ultra wideband aufnehmen kann sondern die unterstützen auch alle sowas wie ein peer-to-peer
Netzwerk das bedeutet wenn ich mein schlüsselbund an dem so ein findet tag hängt ausversehen in einen straßen mülleimer werfe dann sendet
Permanent ein signal aus wie so ein leuchtfeuer vom leucht und jedes iphone zum beispiel was vorbeikommt nimmt das auf und leitet das weiter
Das ist ja auch sehr sinnvoll das so zu machen so ein bisschen ein bisschen schwarm intelligenz
Anrufen ist keine option doch das wird auch funktionieren
Smartphones die an dem mülleimer vorbeilaufen können dieses signal
Ja oder oder ich würde wirklich meine mutter anrufen fragen kannst du mich mal anrufen das geht natürlich auch
Wenn ich die nummerkarte nicht weiß
All empfangen und die senden dann die position an den server ja und dann kann ich auf meinem smartphone sehen
Oh mein schlüsselbund ist da und da im mülleimer dass eure smartphones permanent als findehelfer
Mitarbeiten das kriegt ihr gar nicht mit das läuft alles abgeschottet im hintergrund ich wollte jedenfalls wissen
Funktionieren diese peer-to-peer
Netzwerke wirklich kann ich damit mein fahrrad auch an einem ort wiederfinden an dem nicht unbedingt super viele leute
Vorbeilaufen die antworten darauf seht ihr in diesem video und auch die antwort auf die frage warum ich nicht einfach einen gps tracker
Verwende der die position direkt ins internet schickt bleibt dran ja gut das problem hat gps trackern ist halt die sind deutlich größer als
So ein tag
Insgesamt so und brauchen halt eine iot braucht halt irgendwas zum senden und wahrscheinlich auch akkumäßig hält es da nicht so lang
Wobei ich da gar nicht so sicher bin je nachdem wie oft man das
Senden lässt geht das wahrscheinlich auch voll klar ich hatte mir das mal angeguckt
ein esp 32 mit einem gps modul
Und das ging eigentlich ich habe ich habe mir das mal ausgerechnet wenn man das wenn man das nur irgendwie zweimal täglich
einschalten lässt
zum senden das ist natürlich nichts für live tracken dann
hielt er das glaube ich mit so einer
1200 milliampere
batterie akku
glaube ich zwei jahre zwei drei jahre oder so das war ganz gut
habe ich aber nie umgesetzt das nur mal nur mal überlegt wie man was man machen könnte liebe heckerin
liebe internet surfer herzlich willkommen hierbei
Dieses video wird gesponsert von
Vpn das sind alles homepilot smartphone geräte in smarter gut wickler für eure rollläden oder hier
Hat er gesagt smartphone smart home oder das sind alles homepilot smartphone geräte in smarter gut wickler für eure rollläden
Ich finde immer noch geil dass das auf deutsch einfach gut wickler heißt dieses ding haben wir dafür keinen besseren namen als gut wickler
Ich finde das wort so kacke
Ich habe ja auch einen automatischen gut wickler
Den habe ich aber nie den habe ich aber nie eingebaut
Ich habe mir die ganze hardware dafür gekauft
Um das evaluieren zu kennen zu können aber ich habe mich nie dazu durchringen können das
wirklich zu benutzen
Oder hier smarter heizkörper thermostate und hier in smarter fenster kontakt da seht ihr dann auch wenn ihr gerade im urlaub seid ob jemand
Fenster geöffnet hat und all diese geräte sind 100 prozent
Ihr könnt das einfach selbst einbauen und nicht keine handwerker firma beauftragen
Basis für das homepilot smart do it yourself heißt für mich auch das hat ein offenes protokoll aber das sieht dann nicht so aus
Ein komplett eigenständiges funksystem das seit über zehn jahren in deutschland entwickelt was was sonst
Eigenständiges war natürlich kein zig bz wave oder irgendwas meta kompatibles
obviously
Weil das wäre ja auch zu einfach zu integrieren mit anderen sachen sämtliche geräte infos und daten sind das muss ich gleich mal angucken
Gateway gespeichert man kann das ganze smart home also jederzeit auch ganz ohne internetverbindung bedienen und wenn man will lassen sich auch
unkompliziert geräte von drittanbietern
Aber umgedreht nicht kameras von bosch abos oder exes und so weiter schaut doch mal selbst auf home pilot minus smart home
Das machen wir jetzt auch
Anderweise juckt mich werbung ja nicht aber das machen wir jetzt mal auch home pilot smart home
Let's go super glückliche familie wissen was das witzige an dem bild ist
Ich sehe nicht ein einziges smart home gerät auf dem bild die sind anscheinend auch ohne smart home glücklich
Und die haben bestimmt so eine richtige flashbang webseite ja ein auge
Lösung produkte
Elektrische guchtwickler wenn der scheiß ja nicht so teuer
Rollo-tron
Wenn wenn das funktioniert nicht
Ach die sind das
Hieß das von denen nicht früher hieß das früher nicht du fern von denen
Das haben die einfach unbenannt
Das hieß früher anders das haben die einfach unbenannt
keckel
Kommt es gibt eine home assistant integration die kaum jemand verwendet ja
System man braucht mittlerweile wieder
Das ist nicht das geht nicht einfach über sick wie das ist irgendwo ein eigenes
Irgend so ein eigenes system
Ja, dann habe ich da kein echt kein bock drauf
weiter gucken
Vier stunden geschlafen pipo dad ja verstehe ich vier stunden ist echt wenig liegt schon noch mal hin kann es auch pennen bis zwölf oder so
Erbung ende so ich habe mir vier finde text besorgten original apple airtag ein billig airtag von
Aldi namens maginoten smarttag ein samsung smart warum nicht medium hieß das all die zeug früher nicht immer medium
Ein teil made das apple airtag und maginoten smarttag benutzen apples wo ist
Netzwerk das geht also nur mit apple mobilgeräten der unterschied zwischen original und billig version ist nur das im
Maginoten tag fehlende ultra wideband damit kann man direkt ja und und und das iphones maginoten wahrscheinlich nicht weiterleiten oder
Smartphone display sehen wie weit man von dem airtag entfernt ist so wichtig ist das aber nicht weil man kann die geräte halt auch
Einfach per app piepsen lassen und sie dann so finden der vorteil von billig airtag ja da ist ein loch drin man kann sich das also
Einfach so ohne zusatz hat wer ans schlüsselbund hängen bei apple braucht man noch einen zusätzlichen schlüsselanhänger der original von apple
Übrigens eigentlich ist es komplett unsinnig weil man kann leute die einen tracken von denen man getrackt werden möchte kann man einfach
Bei ios beziehungsweise wenn beide iphone haben hinzufügen und man sein
Ei sein sein handy hat man eh dabei dann tauchen die leute auf in dieser find my contacts find my devices liste
Kostet als das airtag selbst apple verkauft auch airtag schlüsselanhänger von rms für 490 euro
Sag ich jetzt mal nicht was
Schlüsselanhänger von rms für 400 ich dachte es heißt hermes
warum zu das ist
Alter sind die noch ganz bei trost oder was das ist ein stück metall mit ein bisschen ein bisschen
leder zeug dran
Okay das muss jetzt kommen
Wirklich die sind denen ist echt nicht mehr zu helfen
Ausverkauft
Wer kauft den scheiß mann bei gede weimar alles klar
Es ist doch nicht euer ernst mann
Also ich gebe ja für gute qualität und gute produkte auch durchaus geld aus ja
Ich habe mir beispielsweise jetzt zum rennen paar ordentliche schuhe gekauft die kosten auch zwischen 140 und 200 euro je nachdem wo man sie
kauft welcher ausstand aber
Wtf ein ein
15 gramm
Hetzen ich muss ich muss jetzt mal ist das ist das ist das vielleicht größer als ich mir das vorstelle
gut und dass so ein chinesen anhänger 250 kostet ist klar
Ich will jetzt einfach mal wissen wie das aussieht
Ja ist gut
Es ist es ist ein riesen riesen packung schon mal
ein riesen packung für ein bisschen
Ein riesen packung für so ein kleines stück mann
Ich fühle mich speziell
Positionen zusammen
Die tun ja so als packen sie gerade ein goldbarren aus
Das ist wo ich anfange zu wispern
Es ist wie dieses mikrofiber
super soft
wo kehrst das essen das ist
Verpackungsding
So
Alter was eine riesen verpackung für so ein kleines scheiß ding
Ja
Das ist alles oder wie
Das ist doch ein witz oder
Paris made in franz
Moment moment moment leute leute sekunde sehe ich das richtig
Man muss den scheiß sogar noch selbst zusammenbauen ja
Das kommt doch nicht mal für dich zusammengebaut an
Er muss das selbst zusammenbauen
Okay das muss ja ich muss das jetzt hinzufügen sekunde wir brauchen wir brauchen das im aut
ja
Pepo burn money das andere fällt mir da echt gerade nicht mehr dazu ein ich weiß nicht mal was adiletten sind
Sandalen oder sowas
Guckt mal an leute guckt mal das riesen package an und dieses kleine zeug
Ich würde auch gerade riechen oder was
Attention
Ich finde es krass leute dass man das selbst zusammenbauen muss
Und
Alter leute 400 euro das ist wirklich pepo burn money
Ich habe kein problem für hochwertige qualitativ gute sachen auch für werkzeug oder sowas
Geld auszugeben aber das im leben nicht
Das sieht nicht mal sonderlich geil aus
Ist backwards
Das dürfen sie alle mal traurig oder okay alter was ein schwachsinn so wir machen jetzt mal ein eine sache leute
Er muss er tag okay es sieht es sieht vielleicht nicht ganz so aus
Auf den ersten blick auf den ersten blick sieht es doch schon relativ ähnlich aus
Made in china genau
Es sieht tatsächlich aus
Aber da steht nicht da steht nicht hermes er tankt rauf er steht nur er tankt rauf
Wisst ihr leute ich glaube da geht es überhaupt nicht darum dass man was wirklich bekommt
Sieht schon mal hier schepp genäht aus aber okay ich glaube es geht bei dem originalprodukt gar nicht so sehr darauf
Dass man wirklich was dafür bekommt für das geld sondern es geht rein um
status genauso wie erinnert sich noch irgendjemand an diese
Ruby app
Oder war das ein diamant app i am rich
I am rich app
Die gab es im app store zu kaufen für 1000 dollar
Und die app konnte nichts anderes außer anzeigen i am rich acht leute haben die app gekauft
Aber ich bin ja begeistert dass du bei beim china chinesen shop was bekommst was genau so ausschaut
Wahrscheinlich ist es sogar noch das gleiche
Okay aber zurück zum eigentlichen video sonst wird das sonst wird das heute echt ich bin echt wieder echt wieder schockiert man
Guck dir mal die preise an
Wahrscheinlich muss ich das copy paste weil twitch es wieder nicht gecheckt hat
Es sind uhren
Ja gut da kann man sich natürlich so ein airtag ding auch kaufen wenn du einfach 34.000 euro für ein uhr ausgeben kannst
Ganz ehrlich leute ich habe meine
Naja im vergleich zu dem billige garmin uhr
Und die ist mir deutlich lieber weil die mehr kann
Von dem was ich brauche ja die ist nicht mich schade ich
Und die ist sicherlich keine so geile wertanlage wie das vielleicht weiß ich nicht kenne ich mich nicht mit aus weiß ich ob die
Irgendwie ein paar jahre was wert sind
Aber die kann mein puls messen die kann aufzeichnen
Am wie schnell ich renne hat gps drinne
Kann unter anderem auch die uhrzeit anzeigen noch jede menge anderes zeug mehr ich würde gar keine andere uhr anziehen wollen
Einer die preise sind echt normal was wheels kit
Moment die wollen also apple ist schon echt ein bisschen pp oder die wollen 700 dollar für ein paar
rollen haben die man unter einem
Mac machen kann die kriegst du doch die kriegst du doch bei aliexpress bei den china chinesen
Garantiert auch für
Okay, anscheinend nicht
Was man die braucht dass man sein sein dass man seinen mac rollen kann
Okay weiter jetzt
Trägst du die garmin mittlerweile auch nachts ne das ist mir zu unangenehm eine uhr nachts am abend zu haben
Und ich trägt ich ich trage die tagsüber eigentlich auch nur wenn ich auf der arbeit bin dann habe ich den ganzen tag an
Ansonsten habe ich sie nur an wenn ich mich bewege
Wenn ich irgendwas mache
Das heißt die die track bei mir auch nicht ganz richtig und treppe hoch und treppe runter track die auch nicht aber bin jungs
19 euro dazu sage ich jetzt mal nichts so jetzt aber noch zu den anderen tags das teil
Nutzt sein eigenes teilnetzwerk und läuft auf android und ios aber muss dafür die teil app installiert haben das samsung smarttag benutzt
Das samsung eigenes smart things netzwerk und läuft nur auf samsung mobilgeräten ab android 8 damit ihr mal ein gefühl für die pieper
Lautstärke bekommt haben wir die vier tags mal nacheinander piepsen lassen das audio ist unbearbeitet
das ist das ist teil
glaube ich der letzte hier
Das ist teil glaube ich zumindest weil von denen hatte ich auch mal ein gerät und es hat sich so ähnlich angehört
so und jetzt noch zum thema
echt wo
So und jetzt noch zum thema gps tracker ja ja es gibt echte gps tracker für fahrräder nur brauchen die halt eine mobilfunk
Verbindung damit sie ihre position selbst ins netz schicken können also ohne umweg über andere smartphones das benötigt sehr viel energie
deutlich mehr als das bluetooth leuchtfeuer der kleinen findet text und ja man braucht natürlich für mobilfunk daten eigentlich auch
Ein mobilfunkvertrag und eine simkarte. Es gibt aber inzwischen so gps tracker da ist das alles integriert aber das energieproblem bleibt hier zum
Beispiel der cobblestone von copenhagen trackers kostet 100 euro und hat eine fest eingebaute batterie ja und
Was sind das dänische kronen oder wenn man häufig die position ins netz senden will ist die nach wenigen monaten oder sogar
Wochen leer der hersteller verspricht dass die batterie vier jahre lang hält wenn man lediglich einmal am tag die position
Sendet aber a ist einmal am tag meiner meinung nach viel zu wenig um das fahrrad nach einem diebstahl zuverlässig aufzuspüren und b
Stimmt die angabe zumindest laut kundenbewertung nicht in der praxis ist das ding oftwohl früher
Zum vergleich drei der von uns hier getesteten bluetooth findet text nutzen standardbatterien nämlich
Ca2032 knopfzellen die kosten 50 cent das ist nur nach 15 dingen was überall reinkommt was in autoschlüssel reinkommt in teilweise
Fernbedienung reinkommt ist so damit die meistbenutzte
Knopfzelle die so gibt und die halten ungefähr ein jahr lang was wir auch bestätigen können nur der teil hat eine festintegrierte batterie
Es gibt teils aber auch etwas teurer mit wechselbahn batterien also jedenfalls kein wunder dass zum beispiel die
deutsche firma sr mini die früher noch ein
angeboten haben inzwischen komplett haben die das knaum logo geklaut sr mini sieht aus wie das knaum logo
ja
bisschen
Aber der hat fünf kommandant 15 klauen hat nur 14
Die früher noch ein gps tracker angeboten haben inzwischen komplett auf airtex umgestiegen sind weil das einfach viel effizienter und praktischer
Jetzt aber wieder gut am schwitzen beim video aufnehmen kann experiment wir haben also alle vier tracker in gang gesetzt und mit
Kompatiblen smartphones gekoppelt dabei muss ich echt mal apple loben ich war ziemlich beeindruckt wie unglaublich einfach man ein airtex
Aktiviert aus der packung nehmen hier die lasche von der batterie wegziehen und zack sofort poppt auf meinem in der nähe liegenden
Fertig beim billig airtex ging das nicht ganz so leicht das größte problem war die batterie lasche die ich da fast
nicht abgezogen bekommen habe man muss das teil allerdings auch manuell koppeln mit der wo ist aber das hat auch schnell funktioniert bei
samsung und teil dagegen verlief die einrichtung komplizierter vor allem weil man bei beiden erst
accounts beim hersteller anlegen muss aber gut man richtet die dinger ja auch nur einmal ein und dann also ans fahrrad damit für den
apple airtex kann man so eine super unerfällige klingel kaufen air bell heißt die wo man den airtex einfach unten reinsetzt
Kostet 18 euro und gefällt mir echt richtig gut weil man das wirklich von ganz ehrlich
jeder fahrraddieb weiß wahrscheinlich dass es diese klingel gibt und reißt die als erstes ab
außen absolut nicht erkennen kann die anderen tags habe ich mit der bewährten panzer tape methode
eingebaut der plan ging jetzt folgendermaßen
lukas fährt mit meinem fahrrad irgendwohin und ich versuche ihn nur mit den tags am rad zu finden damit lukas nicht selbst die bluetooth signale
der tags aufhängt hat er keinerlei technik dabei außer seiner analogen armbanduhr
ja und los geht's um 13.10 fährt lukas los
ich bin jetzt eine halbe stunde vom verlag weggefahren habe mich hier mitten in den stadtwald irgendwo gegeben und bisher habe ich
ungefähr zehn fahrradfahrer gesehen und zwei fußgänger die hier vorbeigegangen sind eine davon hat ein handy in der hand das heißt die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es irgendwie einer von den trackern hier jetzt angesprochen ist ist auf jeden fall da aber
ob keno mich am ende wirklich findet oder nicht
ja schauen wir mal was wird
So um 14 uhr beginne ich dann ihn zu suchen ich gucke jetzt zum ersten mal in die apps rein und guck was
Taylor das ist eigentlich eine richtige feinfeld idee oder
man versteckt zwei airtags im sitz und macht sich so eine fake klingel dran
dass sie also macht sich eine airtag klingel dran in die man gar kein airtag reinmacht und jeder dieb denkt dann die airtags sind in
der klingel
das ist feinfeld
Also passiert ist ob ich
lukas finden kann beziehungsweise mein fahrrad ich fange an mit der teil app weil ich der ehrlich gesagt die
geringsten chancen ausrechnet
Okay das ist hier die timeline okay das ist die timeline das ist einfach mein weg den ich zur arbeit gefahren bin das heißt
hat keinen standort so ich habe das ding jetzt quasi als
Verloren gemeldet ja bringt nichts so jetzt probiere ich mal samsung aus also die samsung find app mit den smarttags
Letzte aktualisierung
Das ist halt das was ich am anfang gemeint das ist ein riesen vorteil von airtags jedes iphone schickt weiter
vor einer stunde
Und auch der standortverlauf zeigt mir nichts an jetzt kommen wir zum airtag von apple wir fangen mal mit dem billig airtag an
wo ist
Stehe vor heise
Aber mein fahrrad ist angeblich kleines bisschen weiter in der karl wichert allee 15 ist jetzt aber mal gar nicht so weit
entfernt ja ziemlich unbefriedigend teil und samsung zeigen immer noch den
Ausgangspunkt an das heise verlagshaus der airtag zeigt einen ort nun paar hundert meter weiter an das wird nicht lukas versteckt sein
Aber ich fahre trotzdem also ja da hat er sich nicht versteckt aber hier ist ein studentenwohnheim deshalb ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit groß dass hier jemand das airtag funkfeuer aufgefangen hat denke ich mir zumindest nach ein bisschen watterei
Fahre ich mal in den wald in die einriede angeblich europas größter stadtwald zumindest würde ich da an so einem heißen tag wie
Heute hinfahren da ist es nämlich schön kühl so wo ist zuletzt gesehen um 13 16
Also sechs minuten nachdem er losgefahren ist jetzt ist es 14 48
Ich glaube nicht mehr dran ich gucke noch mal ein teil und bei teil hat sich ebenfalls gar nichts getan und jetzt noch mal samsung
Letzte aktualisierung vor zwei stunden wieso fährt er irgendwo hin
Du meinst er ja gucken aber vielleicht einen empfang kriegt
Standortverlauf auch samsung hat nicht mal mitbekommen dass lukas sich vom verlag weg bewegt hat ja aber keine chance die einriede ist viel zu groß
Um lukas und mein fahrrad ohne hilfsmittel zu finden ich lasse mal meine drohne steigen vielleicht
Sehe ich ihn da von oben leider nicht um 15 uhr also fast zwei stunden nachdem lukas losgefahren ist fahre ich wieder ins büro
Das airtag zeigt immer noch die letzte position um 13 16 an also da am studentenwohnheim
Ich habe keine ahnung wo ich suchen soll sind es auch wirklich einige leute an mir vorbeigelaufen
Die irgendwie smartphones in der hand hatten mindestens drei iphones habe ich gezählt zwei davon hat das heißt der tag sinnlos
Der konto war nur wie das verwenden willst als zum fahrrad trecken wenn es geklaut ist
Geht sicherlich ja muss halt ein bisschen glück haben also wo das wo das wahrscheinlich funktioniert ist wenn das fahrrad geklaut wird
Und da steht ein tag irgendwo in der scheune rum
Und irgendwann läuft man zufällig einer vorbei und fängt das auf und schickt es weiter ja aber so live tracking innerhalb kurzer zeit dafür
Also man sieht ja dafür wofür es auch nicht geeignet ist
Zum beispiel um haustiere zu tracken und sowas kannst du komplett knicken
Also definitiv auch bluetooth an also der airtag zumindest muss eigentlich angeschlagen haben also wenn keno mich jetzt nicht findet dann
Kein gutes zeichen um 15 und 39 dann jetzt die sensation jetzt gerade habe ich ein update bekommen
In wo ist in den anderen beiden apps ist nach wie vor
Nicht zu sehen da ist das fahrrad gar nicht von ihr weggekommen
Aber ich habe jetzt ja einen neuen ort kurioserweise sind die positionen laut wo ist von 14 uhr vier und 14 uhr fünf also
Offenbar hat das system eine verzögerung von anderthalb stunden um das sehen seltsam aber ich fahre hin in der hoffnung dass lukas noch nicht
aufgegeben hat
Und liest ein analoges buch es hat geklappt aber halt erst drei stunden nachdem mein fahrrad geklaut wurde
Lukas hat mir dann erzählt dass viele leute an ihm vorbeispaziert sind einige auch mit airpods im ohr die müssen also ziemlich sicher sein signal
Aufgefangen haben aber war da wirklich niemand mit samsung handy dabei die samsung app zeigt nämlich immer noch den alten urteil auch
Okay das experiment hat also funktioniert aber durch die verzögerung beim airtag ziemlich unbefriedigend und vor allem will ich nicht glauben dass samsung
Also der der rest ich dachte mir es irgendwie schon dass das einzige was halbwegs
Funktioniert die airtags sind und teil gar nicht funktionieren deshalb habe ich dann lukas gebeten noch mal mein rad zu klauen und damit in eine
Belebtere umgebung mit in der stadt zu fahren ich bin jetzt auch hier in einer belebten ecke in hannover und ich versuche ihn jetzt zu finden
Ja und das ergebnis ist etwas besser die beiden airtags haben deutlich schneller die fährte aufgenommen samsung etwas später auch aber teil hat
Mal wieder gar nicht funktioniert es liegt vermutlich daran dass das auf überträger smartphones zwingend die teil
installiert hat hat keine saufen bar ist das auch nur sehr wenige handys der fall bevor ich zum fazit komme muss ich unbedingt noch
Mal über das missbrauchspotenzial der tags sprechen sowohl teil als auch samsung können ein standortverlauf
Anlegen bei teil kostet das extra man muss ein abo für 35 euro im jahr abschließen
Ein abo abschließen für die einzige app die nicht funktioniert sehr gute idee will ich genau sehen wann das bluetooth tag
Wo war und zwar auch dann wenn die person die das ding mit sich rumschleppt gar nicht weiß dass es da ist also wenn das zum
Beispiel unter das auto geklebt ist oder in eine handtasche
Eingenäht man bekommt bei samsung und teil tatsächlich auch keine warnmeldung aufs handy wir haben das ausprobiert
Lukas hat alle auf meine accounts aktivierten text zwei tage mit sich rumgeschleppt nur bei den beiden airtags hat die warnung
funktioniert aber auch nur auf lukas iphone auf seinem android telefon
Ein pixel 7 das auch schon das fremde airtags erkennen update bekommen hat nicht also zumindest nicht
Automatisch als er manuell man kann da manuell nach fremden text suchen da hat er das erkannt aber ich meine man kann nicht ständig nach
Text suchen wenn das der fall ist will ich ein pop-up kriegen so bringt es ja nicht viel auf dem iphone bekamen wir übrigens die
Du führst ein unbekanntes airtag meldung immer wenn wir in die nähe unserer wohnungen kam das scheint apple bewusst so
Eingerichtet zu haben schließlich will man nicht dass stalker wissen wo man wohnt man kann also
Bevor man in die wohnung geht schnell woanders hingehen das feind airtag suchen und die batterie rausnehmen wie das geht zeigt die
Warnmeldung auf dem iphone auch direkt an das habe ich nicht gecheckt jetzt das ist echt ganz gut gemacht aber wie gesagt bei teil und
Samsung gibt es keinerlei warnung nun kann man sagen zum glück funktionieren deren beiden suchnetzwerke nicht so gut wie das von apple aber zumindest
Die samsung text dürften in größeren städten für illegale anwendungen echt nutzbar sein
Laut samsung würde die smart things app auf samsung geräten fremde smart text erkennen aber das nützt nun wenig wenn man selbst
Keine samsung mobilgerät verwendet man kann ja immer als schutz noch in samsung phone mit apple und google haben das problem zumindest erkannt und sich
Auf einen stalker waren standard geeinigt damit sollen ios und android standardmäßig fremde findet text erkennen
Wir können aber stand heute sagen ein pixel 7 mit es wäre natürlich cool wenn die das nicht nur erkennen sondern auch weiterleiten können
Belegt euch mal wenn android und apple das weiterleiten da wäre das netzwerk doch deutlich dichter aber das werden die nicht wollen
Erkennt automatisch kein einziges unserer vier text iphones erkennen zumindest fremde er text automatisch aber kein samsung und kein teil das ist echt
Problematisch und sollte schleunig behoben werden wichtig ist vor allem dass samsung und teil mit apple und google bei ihrem gemeinsamen standard
Zusammenarbeiten interesse haben sie zumindest schon bekundet wir werden uns die situation ein paar monate noch mal angucken weil zumindest ich will
Ungern heimlich getrackt werden das geht euch wahrscheinlich ähnlich apropos standard google plant auch ein geräteübergreifendes
Android finden netzwerk zu etablieren was dann so wie das von apple funktionieren soll dass also jedes android telefon auf betriebssystem
Ebene findet text erkennt und die position weiter gibt aber irgendwie wurde das immer wieder nach hinten verschoben
Mal sehen wann das projekt startet im besten fall aber dürfte das neue android finden netzwerk dann zumindest
Das wird dann innerhalb wenn es nicht gut ankommt gleich auf den friedhof wieder geschmissen von google google gibt es ja gibt es ja diese
Seite gilt bei google
Wo alles draufsteht was google bisher rausgebracht hat und eingestellt hat ist schon ein bisschen was
Vieles hat man noch gar nicht gehört
Ich weiß zum beispiel nicht was grasshopper ist
Oder check hart
Jacquard wie auch immer google domains erst letztens ja
Wenn es hierzulande sogar besser funktionieren als das wo ist netzwerk von apple denn in der deutschsprachigen welt hat android einen höheren
Marktanteil als apple in der schweiz ist der appleanteil zwar sehr hoch aber
Androids gibt es hier noch ein bisschen mehr am schönsten wäre natürlich auch hier ein apple und google über
Ja
Aber das wird wohl nicht passieren da denken die firmen leider mehr ans geld als an ihre kundschaft mein fazit ja es
Funktioniert man kann ohne gps tracker ein geklautes fahrrad wiederfinden am besten klappt das mit airtags man kann da auch getrost die billigere
Wo ist kompatibel nicht apple geräte nehmen die gehen genauso gut aber man muss ihm klar sein wenn das fahrrad
Irgendwo im niemandsland ist wo nie jemand mit iphone vorbeiläuft dann hat man problem und man muss die
Verzögerung auf dem schirm haben bis das fahrrad dann endlich in der wo ist app auftaucht dauert halt ein bisschen die text von samsung
Funktionieren leider nur in extrem belebten umgebung und der teil gar nicht bei unseren tests gar nicht funktioniert also das teil
Netzwerk aber hauptsache ein abo für abschließen auf jeden fall am lenker lassen und schlafe damit jetzt auch ein bisschen ruhiger als vorher
In september
Jetzt wissen wir bescheid
Also falls jemand damit auf die idee kommt sein haustier zu tracken oder sowas könnte knicken
Für echtzeit ist schon mal gar nichts
Du verkaufst du verkriegst den airtag im garten um als falls einer deinen garten klaut was kostet ein einfamilienhaus
Wahrscheinlich viel zu viel
Als dass es sich wirklich lohnt
gaben
Ist es nicht der alte der alte mac ja doch dass der alte mac pro der aussah wie ein aschenbecher
war heute schon c++
Das muss jeder mit dem geschirrspüler machen
Nein das müssen wir nicht machen mit dem geschirrspüler
Was haben wir als nächstes
Bann ist disrupting the javascript land. Komm wir gucken eine runde fireship. Fireship hat immer gute videos
Was disrupted bann ich habe raus ich habe letztens gesehen dass bahn version 1.0 da ist
Ich bin ja immer noch skeptisch ob die welt das alles gebraucht hat aber schauen wir mal
Was local host unterschied
127001 war es ist nur das
Das eine ist noch nicht mal eine gültige ip adresse
Und das eine ist zumindest meistens local host
Algorithmen verstehen dann verstehen was vielleicht auch was der unterschied ist
Als gucken wir erst mal wir gucken erst mal was fireship erzählt
23 and you're watching the code report yesterday was a huge day for soy deaths mojo became generally available a super set of python
That's up to 35,000 times haben wir schon gesehen aber nicht open source faster
But javascript also got way faster
Thanks to a new swiss army knife called bun and that means it's time for some new stickers on my macbook pro javascript developers have
Grown tired of reinventing new frameworks. So now we're building entirely new javascript runtimes in the beginning
We had no js then rearranged the letters to make dino and now we've got bun fresh out of the oven
Which just hit 1.0 this morning
Ich finde eigentlich dass also mein deutsches ist immer noch mit abstand das verbreitetste was ich bei denen nicht gecheckt habe am anfang ist
dass sie gesagt haben
Sie
sie unterstützen kein npm
Oder keine keine packages keine bestehen also das ist ja quasi eines der größten vorteile
des javascript ökosystems
das ist für
alles und
Jedes und was es überhaupt gibt irgendein package gibt ich meine im javascript land gibt es tatsächlich packages für
ob eine zahl gleich
gerade oder ungerade ist
Und um nicht zu vergessen es gibt ein package dass ich dann ist ort und dann gibt es ein package dass ich dann ist ist
Ort und es gibt auch ein package was ich nennt ist even
und diese packages werden
Eine halbe million mal in der woche ok das hier nicht
Eine halbe million und eine viertel million mal
Runtergeladen in der woche immer noch und jetzt halt und jetzt haltet euch mal fest wer jetzt denkt
das sind real packages
Und und wer jetzt etwa denkt dass
Das ist sogar
Archived mittlerweile aber wenn man sich den code anguckt das ist alles ja also dafür braucht man nicht unbedingt
Übrigens ist even importiert das andere modul ist dort da hat man schon mal zwei abhängigkeiten für
Warum macht man das kann man doch mit modulo rausfinden ja
Macht er ja auch hier aber vorher guckt er noch ob das eine nummer ist
Zahl und was überhaupt so ja
Warum
Just javascript things
You know and now we've got bun fresh out of the oven which just hit 1.0 this morning
And you should take notice because it can run your javascript code faster than any other tool known to man
But not just that it also acts as a bundler like webpacker v a test runner like jest or karma and a package manager like
Npm or yarn in addition
Npm packages
Apis, but has its own set of highly optimized apis that actually make it fun to build high-performance server-side applications with javascript before we get
Into it though. I want to show you another awesome new tool from our sponsor dev GPT by now. You've heard of tool
baby, come on
Bun on in England stream was like chat GPT and copilot
But dev GPT takes a I code generation to the next level by integrating directly with your git repo giving the AI the full context
Of your tech stack and project after writing a prompt to fix
It's a bug or create a feature
It'll ask follow-up questions to write highly targeted and useful code
Once the code is generated you can then sync those changes to your local project instantly
Then you could prompt it to generate some unit tests to validate that code
It's like having an automated engineer by your side
Who can take care of your github issues and jira tickets instantly without complaining you can try it out for free yourself right now
With the link below, but now let's get back to bun
First of all, how do they make this thing?
So fast one major difference compared to node and dino which uses the v8 engine from chrome bun uses javascript core from safari
Which is going to be optimized stem. Das ist das ist
Das ist ja nicht v8
Das ist webkit javascript zeug
The v8 engine from chrome bun uses javascript core from safari
Which is known to be optimized for faster startup times in addition bun is implemented in the zig programming language
They've put a focus on profiling performance bottlenecks and implement api's in native code
The end result is a hello world with typescript. That's five times faster than yes build
Keep in mind though benchmarks can always be cherry-picked and rarely reflect real-world performance
It's fun to go fast
Only have 12 monthly active users on my website. It doesn't make a huge difference for me
What I care about is the developer experience can bun make my life easier
Well, first up, it's got awesome typescript support out of the box
You can immediately start writing typescript code without any configuration or headaches and it also supports jsx and hot reloading
Which means you don't need any weird dependencies like node mon and concurrently to recompile your code when things change
That's cool. But one of the absolute worst things about node has been the transition from common. Yes to yes modules
What's cool about bun is that you can just use import and require in the same file
Okay, that's everything
This is magically works and it's compatible with existing node.js packages
Which means you don't have to reinvent the wheel for every little thing you want to implement Dino also added npm support as well
Recently, but what I really like about bun is its native api's for example to read and write to the file system
We can access the global bun run time and make a reference to a file then lazily read it or parse its json
That may not seem like a big deal
But in node.js there are three different ways to do the same thing read file with callbacks read file with promises or read file sync
You can actually use all of those in bun but not only are the native api's faster, they're easier
They basically do the same import is the es6 syntax
So the official javascript syntax and require was what node.js came up with before there was import
That's why they switched to the official javascript syntax
But node.js used require for years because there weren't any official javascript modules
And they basically do the same
Certainly not in detail but I don't know much about that
Yes, I think that's not a plus anymore because nowadays you can do that in any programming language
You can even start a web api project in C-sharp with three lines of code
That's really not a new thing anymore
That'll take you pretty far but there's also frameworks that work with bun like Elysia that claims to be 18 times faster than express.js and node
Bun also works with Hano which has been my go-to framework for building api's recently
Bun has tons of other simplifications as well
It takes about two weeks in the javascript land until there's a new hyped framework for something
But when it comes to the big frontend frameworks, there's been a lot of movement in the last few years
It's still in there but it's relatively constant compared to earlier
React is still in the lead
Enterprise business shit still likes to use Angular
Vue is still there
Svelte was added
And a few more
Solid
And for all the React fans
There's also
What's it called?
HTX
Which is new
For HTML
With a bit of javascript
What else is there?
I can't remember
Astro
React isn't even mentioned anymore
SAP
I already had Angular
That's pretty cool
Sadge
Well, now we know that we'll have to use Bun next time
What am I seeing here?
Nobody masters C++
That's normal, it's C++
Nobody knows how to use C++ correctly
Not even the people who design C++ standard
Otherwise they wouldn't build in contradictory stuff
Already saw the PHP video
The PHP video?
What is THE PHP video?
I don't know if it's from him
We saw in a PHP video
That PHP isn't that bad
And I have to agree
I thought it was well thought out
Compared to new C++ standards
No
I just see that it's ugly like night
Especially that it's pure C
And not C++
I don't see anything C++-like
Probably it's the
The
The trailer of what he wants to say
Endless loop
Printf
I don't know what Auth and Service is
Auth and Service isn't mentioned anywhere
No idea where it comes from
Fgets is always a thing
I don't know if it works or not
Yes
With the difference
That it's unnecessarily complicated
And a lot is missing
There's still no HTTP client
In the C++ standard library
I mean
Who needs HTTP nowadays?
It's completely overrated
Nobody needs HTTP
Who uses the internet?
You can do it yourself
You can just program everything in Assembler
You can do everything yourself
But then you have a third-party library
Where we have the problem
To have 30 million headers in C++
Instead of proper modules
And whether C++ modules ever run
Be put there
We create an example class
The class's name is dog
And it has a method speak
And a method that's a setter
By the way
I think the object syntax in C++
Is so ugly
When I see it
What triggers me the most
Is the output formatting
The non-existent
But there's standard format now
They ripped it from Python
It works at least
When I see something like this
Look
It has its logic
No, forget it
Hi hi
And on
Just delete the
I never delete the
Okay, what does he want to tell us?
Ah, standard unique
Oh, this
This syntax is so
So grandios
I'm just saying
Standard vector bool
I just can't
Delete the language
What?
Cucumber is at the start
Chainlore, what weird videos are you sending me?
And what the hell is wrong with his mic?
Whatever
Dude, Chainlore, stop sending me this shit
ASMR content creator
I don't get it
Sometimes you don't have an alternative
If you do microcontroller
And there are lots of them
Or if you use
Unreal
You can't handle it
For everything else
I don't want that
We already did it many times
Not interesting
First time this week
Powershell is actually not bad
It is okay
PowerShell ist super zum Automatisieren, aber interaktiv finde ich PowerShell nicht schön zu benutzen.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Dieses Haus ist 200.000 Euro teurer als geplant.
Ja, Haus bauen ist teuer als fuck, deswegen bin ich froh, dass ich kein Haus bauen musste, sondern das Haus vom Opa geerbt habe.
Weil das Umbauen war, bzw. ich habe es ja gar nicht direkt geerbt.
Aber das Renovieren war schon auch nicht billig, aber mit Sicherheit nicht so teuer wie ein eigenes Haus bauen.
Okay, Zeit mehr, 3 Minuten 56.
Ist das wirklich der private finanzielle Ruin, was wir hier machen, oder können wir es mit einem Leben wirklich nur abzahlen?
Wahrscheinlich könnt ihr es abbezahlen, wenn es so weiterläuft, wie ihr das denkt.
Die denken nämlich so nach dem Motto, wir bleiben für immer zusammen und wir bleiben auch immer hier wohnen und wir werden hier alle mal 85 und alle sind happy für immer.
Das klappt dann bis zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht, bis sie keinen Bock mehr aufeinander haben und sich nach 3 Jahren trennen und dann irgendjemand den Scheiß bezahlen muss.
Und selbst dann, also ein Kollege von mir auf der Arbeit, also auf der alten Arbeit, habe ich euch ja erzählt, hat sich jetzt ein Haus gekauft, bzw. ein Haus bauen oder was auch immer, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man fertig ist, gekauft oder eins bauen wollte.
Und der hat gesagt, der bezahlt jetzt 30 Jahre lang ab.
Der ist ein bisschen jünger als ich, sagen wir mal, der ist 30.
Der bezahlt bis 30 Jahre, Alter.
30 Jahre.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was in 5 Jahren ist, ich habe doch keine Ahnung, was in fucking 30 Jahren ist, man.
Ja, das ist ein gutes E-Mail, das ist brav.
Okay.
Ein Haus zu bauen?
Mein Traum ist es definitiv nie gewesen, ein Haus zu bauen.
Generell Sachen mit körperlicher Arbeit auf der Baustelle.
Nee, nee.
Es gibt Tage, wo ich es bereue, und es gibt Tage, wo ich sage, ja, ich freue mich auf den Einzug.
Abbezahlen ist heutzutage auch billiger als Mieten.
Also ich habe letztens einen Artikel drüber gelesen, ihr wisst, dass ich von solchen Finanzsachen keine große Ahnung habe, aber in dem Artikel stand sinngemäß drin, dass es ja theoretisch lohnen würde, quasi die, auf die Miete zu verzichten, also das, was man als Miete bezahlt, zu nehmen als Finanzierung für ein Haus.
Und so hat man quasi das, sagen wir mal, in Anführungszeichen, das Gleiche bezahlt, nach 30 Jahren, wie wenn man in Miete wohnt, aber man hat am Ende ein Haus.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass es in Deutschland nicht richtig funktionieren würde.
Ich kann euch aber nicht sagen, warum.
So, lasst uns mal angucken.
Ich war wirklich froh, dass wir bei dem Renovieren hier einen Architekt dabei hatten, der täglich auf die Baustelle ist, geguckt hat, und dass wir wirklich, dass wir wenig machen mussten.
Ich hab so keinen Bock, also ich hab schon gekotzt, wo wir hier teilweise Tapete abmachen mussten, und das geilste, also eines der geilsten Sachen beim Renovieren, das weiß ich noch, das wollte ich euch jetzt an der Stelle mal kurz erzählen, das war, am Montag kommt der Typ, um Kacheln an die Wand zu machen im Bad.
So, und der Typ, der verputzt hat die Wände, der ist aber zu spät fertig geworden.
Und jetzt war der Fliesenleger, ja.
Und kurz darauf kam der Typ, der unten den Boden irgendwie ausgleichen sollte von der Höhe, so.
Und zum Glück war das nicht in allen Räumen und so, aber es gibt ja von mir auch Videos von der Baustelle noch, glücklicherweise wurde das Haus ja nicht neu gebaut, sondern wirklich nur ganz recht gründlich renoviert.
Zumindest, wir mussten dann im Bad die Wände trocknen.
Und ich hab da so einen großen, also ich hab da so einen großen Lüfter reingestellt zum Pusten, noch mehr Lüfter reingestellt zum Pusten.
Ich hab alles, was wir haben mitgebracht, von Föns bis Heißluftgebläse und alles.
Und ja, wir hatten so ein großes Pusteding da drinnen.
Aber das hätte bis Montag nicht fertig getrocknet.
Und da standen wir dann samstags da und haben die Wände getrocknet.
Mit allem möglichen, was wir hatten.
Einen halben Tag, einen halben Tag gepustet.
Und da drinnen war es heiß, Alter.
Da war es gefühlt 150 Grad oder so drinnen.
Da war es nicht, da werden wir abgefackelt.
Das war so warm.
Ich stand da nur noch in der Unterhose.
Das war im Winter.
Hi, ich bin Daniel.
Ich bin die Maria.
Und wir bauen hier südlich von Ulm unser Traumhaus zusammen mit unserer Tochter Nora.
Und wir schauen mal, ob sich das Ganze lohnt.
In Ulm, oder nicht nah von Ulm, war ich öfters mal.
Am Nicht-Ellotrix-Besuch, nein.
Da hab ich meine Ausbildung damals gemacht, in der Nähe von Ulm.
Also, die.
Nein, das stimmt nicht.
Meine Ausbildung habe ich in Frankfurt gemacht.
Aber die Firma, bei der ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe, die saß in der Nähe von Ulm.
Und Ulmer Busfahrer ist, glaube ich, das unfreundlichste, was ich je in meinem Leben gesehen habe.
Und ich mag den Schwaben-Dialekt nicht.
Aber das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil ich...
War das nicht mega die Fahrerei für dich?
Doch.
Ich musste da glücklicherweise nicht so oft hin.
Ich muss...
Glücklicherweise nicht so oft hin.
Ich musste da ein paar Mal im Jahr hin.
Das war schon handelbar.
Nice Drohnen-Shot.
Traumhaus hier in der Nähe von Ulm.
210 Quadratmeter groß.
Du magst kein Schwäbisch?
Ne, mag ich nicht.
So ischt es.
Ich mag kein Schwäbisch.
Zehn Zimmer.
Drei Bäder.
Die Arbeiten der Baufirma sind fast fertig.
So Dinger.
Die Arbeiten der Baufirma sind fast...
So Ecken haben wir getrocknet.
Das Wochenende über.
Fertig.
Aber Maria und Daniel machen noch richtig viel selbst, um Geld zu sparen.
Das habe ich halt nicht gemacht.
So viel selbst haben wir nicht gemacht.
Ich habe lieber ein bisschen mehr Geld ausgegeben.
Deswegen hatten wir auch, wie gesagt, einen Architekt am Start.
Der hat das täglich überwacht und geguckt.
Der war sein Geld auch wirklich wert.
Weil der hat dir auch immer klar angeschissen, wenn irgendwas nicht richtig ist.
Weil ansonsten hättest du wieder das Problem gehabt,
der eine sagt,
ah, der, keine Ahnung, der Verputzer hat es verkackt.
Der Verputzer sagt, nein, nein, wie hast du da deine Fliesen dran gemacht?
Dann kommt der Typ und schmeißt irgendwie was auf dir und sagt,
ah, das ist schepp, das liegt aber nicht an mir.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf gehabt.
Zudem kostet das Ganze 200.000 Euro mehr als geplant.
Und wie viel kostet es normal?
Das ist ein bisschen abenteuerlich.
Also ich glaube, das Renovieren bei uns hier im Haus,
das hat knapp 100.000 Euro gekostet.
So über den Daumen gepeilt, ich weiß nicht genau.
So in dem Dreh.
Und jetzt überlegt euch mal, was es gekostet hätte,
wenn das neu gebaut worden wäre.
In diesem wunderbar großen Wohn-Ess-Bereich.
Hier hinten werden wir später mal unser Wohnzimmer aufbauen.
Wir können dann auch hier direkt durch die Glastüre
dann schön raus auf die Terrasse laufen.
Hier hinten werden wir auch eine IKEA-Küche einbauen.
Jetzt stellt euch mal vor, das ist so ultra teuer
und das Haus ist halbfertig.
Stellt euch mal vor, die stellen morgen fest,
die haben keinen Bock mehr aufeinander.
Und dann?
Dann müssen die es irgendwie versuchen zu verkaufen
und dann gehen die mit richtig krass Minus raus.
Küche ist fertig, reicht so.
Wenn die das jetzt verkaufen,
gehen die mit ordentlich Minus raus.
So ein halbfertiges Haus will doch keiner kaufen, oder?
Sagt doch niemand, dass die mit Minus rausgehen.
Doch, ich sag das.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt,
aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass sie das dafür bekommen, was sie da reingesteckt haben.
Zumindest in dem Zustand.
Also inklusive der Elektrogeräte für die Küche.
Letztendlich sind wir uns alle darüber einig,
muss jeder selbst wissen.
Und es ist halt ein Risiko,
was man sich überlegen muss.
Das ist halt so.
Und dann haben wir hier eine riesenlange Arbeitsplatte.
Die geht dann über die komplette Länge hier rüber.
Wir haben genau exakt unter dem Fenster unser Spülbecken.
Die Enden sind das Beste.
Wo wir hoffen, dass das später auch mal aufgehen wird,
weil der Wasserhahn praktisch genau hier in der Mitte hoch gucken wird.
Und wenn wir dann das Fenster aufmachen,
dann geht hoffentlich das Fenster wieder auf.
Dann geht hoffentlich das Fenster einmal am Wasserhahn vorbei.
Wir haben es genau so geplant, wie es jetzt hier dasteht.
Das ist genau unser Gedankengut.
Und das merken wir jetzt, wenn wir hier reingehen.
Okay.
Noch sieht man da ja nicht so viel, oder?
Hier war ein Kompromiss.
Doch, die gehen wahrscheinlich durch das Haus
und sehen schon in ihrem Kopf immer, wie es fertig aussieht.
Wir nicht, aber die schon.
Maria wollte unbedingt ein Ankleidezimmer haben.
Also hierhin.
Ein was?
Was macht man mit einem Ankleidezimmer?
Da hat man dann drei Kleiderschränke stehen und zieht sich an.
Na gut.
Gar nicht so blöd, wenn ich mir so recht überlege.
Gar nicht so blöd, wenn man sehr viele Klamotten hat.
Wenn man sehr viele Klamotten hat
und morgens tatsächlich guckt,
ziehe ich heute das an, ziehe ich heute das an?
Why not?
Die wissen es am besten, was für sie wichtig ist.
Wie hoch die Deck?
Ich glaube, die ist gar nicht so dicke.
Das ist einfach nur ein bisschen schräg hier neben.
Und vielleicht müssen ja noch irgendwelche Kabel und so drunter.
Sieht eigentlich ganz normal hoch aus.
An dieser Wand kommen vollflächig Schränke hin.
Und das hier wird verkleidet mit USB-Platten und mit Regibs.
Da kann man leider nicht mehr durchsehen.
Die guten USB-Platten.
Sowohl links als auch rechts kann man daran vorbeilaufen.
Und vom Schlafzimmer aus kommen wir dann hier direkt ins Badezimmer rein.
Ich nehme euch da noch kurz mit.
Ja, unsere Badewanne ist schon da.
Und warum kostet es jetzt mehr?
Und hier hinten haben wir dann eine riesengroße begehbare Dusche.
Ja, und warum kostet das jetzt mehr?
Oder auf die Wände 1,20m auf 60 große Fliesen.
Also wann kommt denn jetzt der eigentliche Knackpunkt,
warum das mehr kostet?
Bei den YouTube-Videos, die ich mir angeschaut habe,
sollte es funktionieren,
1,20m auf 60 Fliesen an die Wand zu legen.
1,20m auf 60 Fliesen an die Wand zu kleben.
Aber wir lassen uns mal überraschen.
Okay, dann gehen wir mal runter.
Mein Verdienst ist gerade eben 70%, arbeite ich im Moment.
Elternzeit bis nur drei Jahre alt ist, bekomme ich im Moment 2.600 Euro raus.
Und theoretischerweise wären es drei,
aber ich zahle noch 400 Euro für meinen Flumenwagen,
der dann natürlich andere Vorteile mit sich bringt.
Bei mir ist es so, ich arbeite gerade auch Teilzeit und Elternzeit.
Und da verdiene ich ca. 1.200 Euro netto.
Also wir verdienen im Endeffekt gemeinsam zusammen im Monat 4.500 Euro netto.
Inklusive Kindergeld, bayerischen Familiengeld und so weiter.
Also wir haben 4.500 Euro netto im Monat zur Verfügung.
Genau.
Ja und wie jetzt? Und warum kostet das jetzt mehr?
Warum haben wir das geguckt?
Ich fühle mich gebatet.
Was ist hier los?
Ich dachte, da kommt jetzt irgendwie noch was.
Warum das so viel teurer geworden ist?
War das einfach nur eine Cross-Promotion für die ARD-Mediathek oder was?
Alter.
Dazu fällt mir jetzt ja echt nur noch ein.
You got gebated.
You got, you got gebated.
Ge-ge-ge-ge-ge-ge-bated.
Aber wir gehen jetzt sicherlich nicht in die ARD-Mediathek.
Liest ihr die Videobeschreibung durch? Nö.
Lese ich mir nix mehr durch hier.
Die habe ich gebatet, da wird nix durchgelesen.
Was steht da drin?
Ja klar, weil auch jeder immer zuerst die Videobeschreibung liest.
Ihr lest immer die Videobeschreibung, bevor ihr ein Video guckt.
Wer macht's nicht?
Ja, natürlich macht ihr das alle.
Ob-obviously.
Lohnen sich teure elektrische Zahnbürsten?
Ich benutze ab und zu eine.
So teuer ist die aber nicht.
Weil man ganz hinten, oftmals nur hinten, ganz oben links hinter den Zahn,
sonst mit normalen Zahnbürsten nicht gescheit hinkommt.
Du putzt nur ab und zu mit elektrischer Zahnbürste.
Ich benutze das nicht jedes Mal.
Ich benutze die nur dafür, ja.
Ich benutze die nur manchmal für ganz oben links hinten.
Hast du schon mal ein Bart-KI probiert? Nee.
Was ich jetzt habe, was super praktisch ist,
was ich jetzt habe, was super praktisch ist,
Interdentalbürsten.
Das benutze ich seit jetzt ungefähr,
was weiß ich, einem halben Jahr oder so.
Das ist wirklich praktisch.
Du kommst viel besser rein,
als mit der normalen Zahnbürste, ja.
Ich hab mir da erst so ein paar Packen gekauft seit einem halben Jahr.
Und das ursprünglich war ja,
weil der Zahnarzt meinte, es wäre ein bisschen entzündet.
Das liegt nicht am Zahn, das wäre entzündet.
Und dann habe ich angefangen, damit die Zwischenräume zu putzen oben links.
Weil man da, was macht man damit?
Man schiebt das zwischen die Zähne unten.
Unten, wo ein bisschen Platz zwischen den Zähnen ist.
Je nachdem gibt es ja auch bis zu 0,2 Millimeter Größe.
Und seitdem, es hat am Anfang übelst weh getan beim Putzen und Nachputzen,
weil es halt entzündet war zwischen den Zähnen.
Und seitdem ich das jetzt aber regelmäßig mache,
ist es komplett weg.
Es blutet nicht mehr, es tut nicht mehr weh.
Und dementsprechend kann ich das wirklich empfehlen.
Also wenn ihr irgendwie ein bisschen Probleme zahnfleischmäßig habt,
und es euch irgendwie wehtut an Zähnen, zwischen Zähnen,
und es nicht die Zähne selbst sind,
nehmt diese Bürsten.
Mal gucken, welche euch da gut gefallen.
Kann ich wirklich empfehlen, ist top.
Hast du schon einmal versucht,
diese IP-Adresse hier anzupingen?
Warum erhält man dann eine Antwort vom Localhost?
Handelt es sich bei diesen beiden IP-Adressen etwa um dieselbe?
Wir lassen uns das jetzt erklären.
Also streng genommen ist 0000 gar keine gültige IP-Adresse.
IP-Adresse 127.0.0.1 ist eine spezielle Adresse,
die auf jedem Computer als Loopback-Adresse definiert ist.
Diese Adresse wird oft auch als Localhost bezeichnet,
was bedeutet, dass sie auf den aktuellen ...
Da hat er recht, aber ich zeige euch mal was.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er darauf eingeht.
Ich zeige euch mal was.
Ping 127.0.0.2.
Leute, was passiert jetzt?
Also hier sind wir uns ja einig, ne?
So, was passiert jetzt?
127.0.0.2.
Was passiert da jetzt?
Siehe da, es funktioniert!
Und was meint ihr, was bei 3 ist?
Es funktioniert auch!
Und was meint ihr, was bei 69 ist?
Das funktioniert auch!
MonkaS!
Und jetzt kommt die Preisfrage, Chatgy.
Was passiert hier?
420, das ist keine gültige IP.
Es geht auch!
MonkaS!
Wer hat das gedacht?
Und was passiert hier?
Es geht auch!
Also man erkennt, glaube ich, das System so langsam.
Aber jetzt ist die Frage, was passiert hier?
Das funktioniert nicht.
Zumindest unter Linux.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es unter Windows auch so ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, unter Windows ist es auch so.
Dieser gesamte Adressbereich ...
Das gesamte 127.8.
Das gesamte 127.8 ist es quasi.
Das ist gemappt auf LogLoss.
... Computer verweist, auf dem man sich gerade befindet,
unabhängig von der tatsächlichen Netzwerkverbindung.
Ja.
I hacked LogLoss.
... 127.0.0.1 verwendet,
kommuniziert er also mit sich selbst über das lokale Netzwerkinterface.
Damit ist auch klar, was dieses Meme hier bedeutet.
There is no place like 127.0.0.1.
Like home, ja.
Normalerweise heißt es ja,
there is no place like home.
Und im Prinzip stellt 127.0.0.1
die Heimatadresse auf dem eigenen Computer dar.
Daher,
there is no place like localhost.
Wenn wir beispielsweise einen Xampp server ...
Oder wisst ihr, was richtig cringe ist?
Die Leute, die anstatt localhost,
localhorst sagen.
Das sind die gleichen,
die nicht Windows,
sondern windoof sagen.
Kennt ihr so Leute?
Ich finde das immer richtig,
richtig Dice of Cringe,
finde ich das.
Aber lokal auf unserem Rechner starten.
Das habe ich ja schon 20 Jahre nicht mehr gesehen, ey.
Winzig, weich, windoof.
Ja, das ist auch,
das ist so cringe, Alter.
... und die URL-Leiste 127.0.0.1
oder auch einfach nur localhost anbieten.
Und wann ist das Video von vor 10 Tagen?
Dann werden wir auf die Default-Page
des Servers auf unserem eigenen ...
Sofern er an Lootbag lauscht,
dann geht das.
... Computer angeleitet.
Dass du also den localhost nicht pingen kannst,
ist demnach nicht möglich.
Denn du solltest dich schließlich immer selbst erreichen können.
Wichtig, 127.0.0.1
ist nicht die IP-Adresse,
über die andere Computer
einen selbst im lokalen Netzwerk ansprechen können.
Da hat er recht.
Wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise von einem anderen Computer
diese Seite hier aufrufen möchte,
muss ich zuerst mit ifconfig oder ipconfig,
wenn ich mich auf einem Windows-Rechner befinde,
die IP-Adresse im Netzwerk herausfinden
und diese dann von dem anderen Rechner aus ...
Wobei die coolen Leute,
die coolen Leute ja heute auch nicht ifconfig,
sondern ipadd verwenden.
Warum? Weil es cooler ist.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht, warum.
Nur, dass das ifconfig halt oftmals
nicht defaultmäßig mitkommt mehr.
Früher war es immer ifconfig.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
die noch cooleren nehmen ipa, ja.
Oder noch cooleren nehmen ipadre.
Geht auch ipadre?
Ja, geht auch.
Die Ausgabe ist ein bisschen kompakter.
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen,
ich persönlich bin ja ein ifconfig-User.
Also ich benutze eigentlich lieber ifconfig.
Ich kann euch weder sagen, warum,
vielleicht, weil ich die Ausgaben
ein bisschen übersichtlicher finde.
Jett, seid ihr ifconfig-Enjoyer oder eher ip?
IP-Command-User.
Ifconfig.
Ich weiß, dass es deprecated ist,
aber ich benutze trotzdem lieber ipadd.
Aufrufen.
0.0.0.0 ist hingegen eine nicht-routbare IPv4-Adresse,
die eine andere Bedeutung hat.
Die eigentlich, ich glaube,
gar keine richtig gültige IP ist.
Also zumindest unter Windows, glaube ich, geht das nicht.
Unter Linux glaube ich, dass es funktioniert.
Ja.
Das ist irgendwie gealiased auf localhost.
Keine Ahnung.
Das sind aber sowieso Feinheiten.
Sie wird als unbestimmte oder beliebige Adresse verwendet,
wenn ein Server auf die Adresse 0.0.0.0...
Man benutzt das beispielsweise gerne bei Firewall-Regeln,
um any zu symbolisieren.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du sagst, es ist erlaubt von any,
dann ist es oftmals 0.0.0.0.0.0.
Also als Filtermaske.
...dass er auf allen verfügbaren Netzwerkinterfaces lauscht
und auf eingehende Verbindungen von allen IP-Adressen
auf dem Host wartet.
Oder für Interface-Binding.
Binden bedeutet im Allgemeinen,
dass der Server sich auf eine bestimmte Netzwerkadresse
und einen Port festlegt.
Im Prinzip, von wo er Verbindungen annimmt.
Also auf was er Verbindungen annimmt.
...sagt dem Betriebssystem, auf welche IPv4-Adresse
und auf welchen Port er auf eingehende Netzwerkverbindungen
warten soll.
Das wird zum Beispiel genutzt,
um in Python einen Server zu programmieren.
Wenn du beispielsweise mit dem Befehl python-m...
Es ist kein Global Broadcast.
Wenn du Broadcast haben willst,
das ist meistens dann sowas wie 2 von 5.
Allerdings passend zum Netz.
Es muss nicht zwangsläufig 2 von 5 sein.
...HTTP-Server,
ein bereits vorgefertigtes Skript
zur schnellen Bereitstellung eines Servers startest,
dann wird dir die Meldung
Serving HTTP on 0.0.0.0...
Und jetzt Netstat hinterher...
Ups, sorry.
Ich wollte gar nicht so laut klatschen.
Wenn du jetzt Netstat hinterher haust, siehst du es auch.
Python bindet also nicht auf die Localhost-Adresse
127.0.0.1,
sondern auf die unbestimmte Adresse 0.0.0.0.
Das ist auch notwendig,
denn wenn du den Server selbst
über einen Socket programmierst
und als Adresse 127.0.0.1 einträgst,
wird dir bei dem Verbindungsversuch
über einen Python-Client
von einem anderen Computer aus
die Meldung Connection Refused angezeigt.
Man könnte einfach Curl benutzen.
Aber das ist natürlich nichts
für echte Python-Hacker-Mads.
Wir müssen uns nicht nur lokal auf dem Rechner befinden,
auf dem auch der Server läuft.
0.0.0.0 wird oft in Server-Konfigurationen verwendet,
wenn der Server auf allen Netzwerkinterfaces des Hosts
verfügbar sein soll.
Außerdem kann es dabei helfen,
den Server von Clients
auf verschiedenen Netzwerkadressen erreichbar zu machen.
In Kombination mit einem Port,
z.B. 1337,
gibt die IP-Adresse an,
auf welchen Netzwerkinterface und Port
der Server auf eingehende Verbindungen wartet.
Ob man dafür nun 127.0.0.1
oder 0.0.0.0 nutzt,
hängt von den Anforderungen des Servers ab.
Wenn der Server nur auf demselben Computer
lokal erreichbar sein soll,
verwendet man 127.0.0.1,
also den Local Host.
Wenn der Server von anderen Geräten
im lokalen Netzwerk aus erreichbar sein soll,
verwendet man entweder
die IP-Adresse des lokalen Netzwerkinterfaces,
also z.B. die 192.168.56.1,
also die IP-Adresse,
die der Rechner im Netzwerk hat,
oder 0.0.0.0,
um auf allen Netzwerkinterfaces zu lauschen.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Oh, 23 Minuten.
Das geht nicht.
Ich habe Hunger.
Ich muss was essen.
Alle 60 Minuten.
Oh, das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Das ist mir zu lang.
Videospiele cracken.
Illegal, aber moralisch vertretbar.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Das ist von Hermes.
Das ist Werbung für eine Ausbildung bei Hermes.
Da wollte ich ja mal bei Gelegenheit reingucken,
was Hermes so zu bieten hat.
Gibt es Lachs mit Nudeln?
Nein, es gibt heute nicht Lachs mit Nudeln.
Heute gibt es nicht Lachs mit Nudeln.
Ratet mal, was es heute gibt.
Ihr kommt nie drauf.
Es gibt bei mir Samstag immer zwei verschiedene Sachen.
Es gibt entweder Lachs mit Nudeln
oder Lachs mit Nudeln.
Nein, es gibt heute kein Lachs mit Nudeln.
Es gibt zwei Sachen bei mir Samstags immer.
Es gibt entweder Lachs mit Nudeln
oder es gibt Nudeln mit Tomatensauce.
Heute gibt es Nudeln mit Tomatensauce.
Und es ist Sonntag.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber das Essen ist immer noch von Samstag übrig.
Deswegen esse ich das heute.
Also bei mir gibt es Samstags entweder Nudeln mit Lachs
oder Nudeln mit Tomatensauce
und ordentlich Parmesankäse drüber.
Und den Rest futtere ich dann Sonntag noch.
So sieht es aus.
Was Kleines können wir noch gucken.
Schauen wir uns das an.
Videospiele cracken. Illegal, aber moralisch verdrehbar.
Naja.
Gucken, was er dazu sagt.
Lass die Finger von Opera.
Echt, warum?
Weil China-Chinesen-Browser.
Das sage ich die ganze Zeit schon.
Seit Opera zu den China-Chinesen gehört,
will ich davon nichts mehr wissen.
Aber warum? Warum? Was sagt er?
Influencer werben aktuell für den Browser Opera
und dessen Gamer-Version Opera G.
Was zum Teufel ist im Hintergrund los?
Die Musik, Alter.
The thing I spent a long time using recently
is the Opera Desktop Browser.
Mit denen wollte ich auch schon mal Werbung machen.
Wisst ihr, warum das nicht geklappt hat?
Eigentlich spricht das
eigentlich spricht das sogar für die,
warum das nicht geklappt hat.
Die wollten, dass ich Werbung mache
für ihren RGB-Gaming-Browser.
Also Opera GX war das dann.
Und wir waren uns da auch schon
so mehr oder weniger einig.
Und es scheiterte daran,
dass ich gefragt habe,
so, okay, also,
muss ich das Produkt wirklich für das Video benutzen
und muss ich das wirklich gut finden?
Ich habe keine Probleme damit,
was zu bewerben,
wenn es klar ist,
dass es Werbung ist,
auch wenn ich das nicht gut finde.
Also wollt ihr,
wollt ihr, dass ich sage
in dem Video,
dass ich das persönlich empfehle
und dass ich das gut finde?
Dann haben die halt gesagt,
ja, das wollen sie.
Da habe ich ihnen halt zurückgeschrieben,
ja, aber ich halte von eurem Browser nichts.
Ich mag euren Browser aber nicht.
Und daraufhin haben die dann gesagt,
ich habe kein Placement.
Eigentlich lustig, oder?
Ich bin wahrscheinlich der Einzige,
der das so gesagt hat.
Das spricht aber eigentlich echt für die, ja.
Spricht eigentlich.
Ich finde aber auch,
es spricht ein bisschen für mich,
auch weil ich nichts als,
ich empfehle es,
verkaufen wollte,
was ich nicht mag.
Es spricht tatsächlich für beide.
Shoutout an Opera GX.
So, download the upgraded version
of the Opera Browser.
Ich nutze seitdem kein...
Alter, was hat der Typ für einen
komischen Kompressor da am Start?
...einen anderen mehr.
Unmenschlich cool und modern.
Dass sich andere Browser anfühlen...
...fühlen wie aus der Windows XP Zeit.
Seit wann gehört das den Chinesen?
Oh, schon lange.
Lange.
Ich glaube, das bestimmt,
ich weiß nicht, ob es 10 Jahre ist oder so,
die haben das schon lange gekauft.
...browser for anyone remotely
interested in tech.
In meiner Kommentarspalte,
als ich vor dem neuen Update
von Google Chrome gewarnt habe,
war Opera GX der mit Abstand
meistgenannte Browser,
den ihr benutzt,
um sicher vor der Datenkrake Google zu sein.
Sogar im Stream letzte Woche
wurde ich darauf angesprochen,
dass Opera GX meine.
Und ja, ich habe auch schon
einige Sponsoring-Angebote
vorliegen gehabt von Opera GX.
Da bin ich mal gespannt,
warum es bei ihm nicht geklappt hat.
Warum der Browser nicht nur
ein bisschen problematisch,
sondern richtig gefährlich werden kann,
das erfahrt ihr hier.
Und ja, es wirkt schlimmer,
je tiefer man reingeht.
Und genau das tun wir heute.
Ich versuche hier übrigens
nicht ganz so technisch zu werden
wie bei Opera GX.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung,
was da jetzt kommt.
Ich habe immer einen großen Bogen
um Opera gemacht,
seit es China-Chinesen-Zeug ist.
Wenn jemand einen Browser benutzen will,
der ein bisschen ist wie der alte Opera,
der kann Vivaldi benutzen,
weil Vivaldi-Browser
ist von dem ehemaligen Opera-Erfinder.
Wenn ich nach Vivaldi suche,
ist es natürlich blöd,
weil Komponisten und Browser
und so.
Also ihr erkennt auch schon
den Zusammenhang an der Stelle.
Erfinder, ja.
Von dem gleichen Typ
oder von den gleichen Typen.
Zumindest von dem gleichen Typ.
Ob Brave-Browser empfehlenswert ist,
keine Ahnung.
Ich verstehe eh nicht,
warum man was anderes verwendet
als Firefox und Chrome.
Die ganz edgy Leute,
die sagen, ich will das nicht.
Die können auch Edge verwenden.
Das leuchtet mir nicht ein.
... Experimente allerdings immer viel Zeit benötigen,
danke ich heute unserem Sponsor...
Unter der Haube ist es ja außerdem
auch noch überall Chrome, ja.
... Video.
Datenbroker,
die weltweit Daten verkaufen,
sind ein riesiges Problem,
das wir auch noch in diesem Video
weiter besprechen werden.
Diese Daten werden zwar oft legal erworben...
Ach, das ist Werbung?
Dazu habt ihr das Recht.
Klar, es gibt wahnsinnig viele solcher Broker
und es ist meine Arbeit,
sie alle anzuschreiben,
aber einen schaftigen 60% Rabatt mit meinem Code.
Zurück zu Opera und Opera GX.
Sie positionieren sich ganz klar aktuell
als die coolen Browser,
die Browser für Gen Z,
für echte Gamer.
RGB Gaming, ja.
Das sieht man vor allem an ihrem Twitter.
Sorry, X-Account.
Frisst 80% weniger RAM.
Ihr könnt sogar die Hardware-Ressourcen
limitieren, Designs anpassen
und ihr habt RAM.
Die Hardware-Ressourcen limitieren,
Designs anpassen
und ihr habt direkt Twitch
und Discord in der Seitenleiste.
Dann noch ein Gaming-Release-Kalender,
integrierter App-Blocker und...
Das ist halt so ein Ding...
Niemand braucht das.
Ich verstehe nicht, was das...
Also, wozu?
Also, ich meine, Discord-Tab.
Okay, ja, meinetwegen.
Das Einzige...
Also, ich habe mir das natürlich auch mal angeguckt,
das Ding.
Dass du irgendwie
unterschiedliche Themes hast,
aber eingebaut.
Aber was hast du für alle anderen Browser?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
...deine Geheimnisse sicher
mit einer kostenlosen VPN.
Erstmal, eine VPN?
Die VPN?
VPN steht für Virtual Private Network.
Ja, gut.
Da würde ich bei den China-Chinesen
nicht so genau drauf achten,
dass sie das ordentlich übersetzen.
Aber auch der normale Opera
ohne GX wirbt speziell
mit Privatsphäre.
Gleichzeitig wird KI
in Form eines Chatbots integriert
und sogar auf Web3,
also Krypto, NFT und Co. gesetzt.
Wahnsinn.
Spätestens ab dem Punkt wäre ich raus, Alter.
Endlich Fortschritt
und das alles gratis für uns.
Und so viel kann ich sagen,
es sind nicht die Features,
die das Problem sind.
Zumindest nicht, welche Features es sind.
Ich will mal verstehen,
woher kommt eigentlich das Geld?
Wer finanziert diesen Browser,
der uns alle sponsoren will,
wenn wir Endkunden ihn eigentlich sogar gratis bekommen?
Opera verdient Geld mit Ads.
Das ist erstmal recht einfach zu sehen.
Als Firma kann ich nämlich
in einem Ad-Manager Werbung
für meine Dienste schalten.
Die meisten User sind laut Opera
zwischen 18 und 24 Jahren alt,
die zweitmeisten 25 bis 34.
Gen Z und Gamer eben, wie gesagt.
Die Werbung ist in Browser
oder dem Newsfeed integriert.
Und was braucht man für Ads?
Richtig, Daten.
Und mit einem Browser
ist das am einfachsten von allem.
Welche Informationen hat denn so ein Browser?
Naja, fangen wir vorne
mit dem technischen Experiment an.
Wir haben hier einen Browser,
den wir jetzt mal ausprobieren wollen.
Fangen wir vorne
mit dem technischen Experiment an.
Wenn ich den Browser starte,
ohne dass ich irgendetwas selbst tue,
verbindet sich der Browser
mit opera.com.
Das ist auf der einen Seite
natürlich logisch und nötig,
damit der Browser prüfen kann,
ob es zum Beispiel Updates gibt.
Gleichzeitig liefert es aber Opera
auch meine IP-Adresse,
die genutzt wird,
um die Sprache zum Beispiel
für Websites zu ermitteln.
Und das macht wahrscheinlich
so gut wie nahezu alles
mit einem eingebauten Updater.
Also insofern.
Deswegen sind Package-Manager
ja auch nice.
Da muss nicht jedes Programm
seinen eigenen Updater mitbringen.
Also das würde ich jetzt
noch nicht mal so kritisch sehen
an der Stelle.
Opera von euch
einen ziemlich genauen Standort hat.
Dazu liefert Opera euch jetzt
aber auch noch eine UUID,
die in eurer Installation hinterlegt ist.
Damit kann Opera,
auch wenn ihr beispielsweise
das Smartphone mit nach Australien nehmt,
eindeutig erkennen,
dass immer noch ihr das seid
und nicht irgendjemand anders.
Die Opera Server liefern danach
noch eurem Browser einige Werbepartner
wie Amazon oder booking.com.
Das sind die,
die ihr am Ende auf der Startseite
nach der Installation sehen könnt.
Außerdem wird übermittelt,
woher ihr den Browser habt.
Bis jetzt,
soweit noch Standard,
leider für viele Sachen heutzutage.
Anschließend wird nach euren Addons geschaut
und die werden auf Updates überprüft.
Und wer jetzt sicher sein will
vor der Datenkrake Google,
den muss ich hier enttäuschen.
Der schickt es halt
zu den China-Chinesen.
Kannst dir aussuchen,
wem du den Kram gibst.
Google immer kontaktiert.
Wirklich immer.
Wenn ihr jetzt anfangt,
wird automatisch
jede einzelne aufgerufene Website
an Opera geschickt.
Also jede.
Das ist erstmal eine Sicherheitsfunktion,
bei der Opera bei sich
auf dem Server prüft,
ob diese Seite eine bekannte Phishing.
Ja, das macht Google ja auch.
Wobei ich nicht weiß,
ob Google es bei jeder Seite macht
oder ob die das irgendwie runterladen
und dann Hashes abgleichen oder sowas.
Bösartige Seite es.
Aber genau dadurch
wird es versucht.
Aber zu Operas Verteidigung.
Es wird nur der Domain-Namen übermittelt.
Also bei diesem YouTube-Video
wird beispielsweise nicht
watch?vgleichid übermittelt,
sondern nur youtube.com.
Dadurch weiß Opera nicht,
welches Video ihr gesehen habt,
sondern nur,
dass ihr auf YouTube wart.
Diese Funktion ist übrigens
natürlich nur ein Vorwand
für die Firmen,
euren Browser-Verlauf klauen zu können.
Ihr könnt die Funktion
deaktivieren in den Einstellungen
unter
So wie das zum Beispiel
vor bösartigen Websites.
auch U-Block macht.
U-Block.
Auf die Funktion sollte man sich
übrigens ähnlich verlassen.
Diese Blocklist funktionieren
in meiner Erfahrung immer erst
eine Woche ungefähr zu spät.
Und hier übrigens ein Fun-Fact,
der sogar belegt,
dass selbst wenn ich diese Funktion
bei Opera deaktiviere,
wird weiterhin jede einzelne Domain,
die man besucht,
an Opera gesendet,
auch wenn die Funktion aus ist.
Und selbst wenn ich den
Inkognito-Modus aktiviere,
ihr wisst schon,
der, der für extra private
Aktivitäten gedacht ist,
wird jede Domain an Opera übermittelt.
Ja, das ist ja auch so ein Ding.
Das habe ich ja schon mal vor Urzeiten
auch mal in einem Video bei mir gehabt,
wo Leute immer noch denken,
dass der Inkognito-Modus im Browser
dich irgendwie anonym macht.
... Wellenlänge mit Googles Chrome.
Schütze deine Privatsphäre.
Ich konnte damit übrigens
die Ergebnisse vom Kukertz-Block
nochmal verifizieren.
Aber hey, für eure Privatsphäre
gibt es ja zum Glück noch diesen VPN,
der gratis dabei ist, richtig?
Opera VPN ist technisch gesehen
kein VPN,
sondern nur ein Browser-Proxy.
Nur die Anfragen aus dem Browser
werden durch den Server geschoben.
Nichts anderes.
Das ist zwar erstmal kein Problem,
ist aber irreführendes Marketing,
weil es so einfach falsch ist.
Zu diesen ganzen öffentlichen Statements
werden wir noch ein paar Mal kommen.
Dazu hat die Quelle,
die ich euch unten verlinke, festgestellt,
dass zwar OpenVPN und WireGuard
auf der Website beschrieben wird,
also Technologien für VPNs,
aber im Grunde wird nur HTTPS over TLS genutzt.
Also nicht die gängigen Technologien,
die VPNs schnell und sicher machen.
Und der VPN wiederum
macht nichts anderes,
als eure Browser-Anfrage an Opera zu schicken
und von dort dann an die...
By the way, dadurch,
dass die werben mit Werbeblocker und sowas
nur über dieses VPN,
bedeutet auch,
dass die jede Webseite lesen können von dir.
Was echt fragwürdig ist,
weil sonst könnten sie keine Werbung blocken.
Was sehr fragwürdig ist
und was normalerweise auch
nicht funktioniert,
es sei denn,
du trustest explizit dem Opera-Zertifikat,
was normale Browser nicht machen,
aber Opera wahrscheinlich schon,
ist SSL von OpenVPN
und besser als SSL von HTTPS.
OpenVPN macht kein SSL.
OpenVPN ist auf einer ganz anderen
Schicht unterwegs.
Im Osi-Modell.
OpenVPN ist
das baust du nicht auf HTTP-Ebene auf,
sondern eins weiter drunter.
OpenVPN ist quasi
TCP-Verbindung
und darüber
du bekommst deine eigene IP
und bekommst quasi ein eigenes Netz.
Du musst eine Route setzen
und dann geht dein Traffic darüber,
verschlüsselt
und SSL ist halt nur
HTTP.
Ja gut, es kann sein,
dass die
OpenSSL
für die Encryption-Versionen
verwenden.
Das mag sein.
Ich meine im Prinzip
ist HTTP,
TLS selbst
ja auch nicht auf HTTP-Ebene,
sondern auch eins unten drunter.
Das kann man ja auch sehen,
wenn man sich das mit Wireshark anguckt.
Stimmt, du hast sogar recht.
Standardmäßig ist es sogar UDP.
Das stimmt schon.
Das ist auch eins unten drunter,
weil das ist ja nicht,
also du kannst ja kein HTTP machen
darüber,
wenn es auf HTTP aufsetzt.
Das ergibt ja keinen Sinn.
Das ist auch eins unten drunter.
Das ist auch der Grund,
warum du normalerweise
kein HTTPS über einen Proxy
gescheit machen kannst.
Sobald HTTPS über einen Proxy geht,
gibt es nur zwei Varianten.
Entweder unterstützt der Proxy,
ich glaube Connect heißt das,
eher vier Weiterleitungen
von TLS-Sessions
oder
du vertraust dem Proxy-Zertifikaten,
der kann reingucken,
was du normalerweise nicht machen willst.
Kannst du mal den Unterschied
der oberen zwei Schichten,
ich habe keine Ahnung,
was sind die oberen zwei Schichten,
Presentation und Session?
Keine Ahnung,
weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Das ist eh alles ein bisschen PP-Gar
und Oldschool,
OpenVPN,
es stimmt übrigens auch gar nicht,
was ich erzählt habe,
also OpenVPN geht ganz normal
IP-mäßig übers Internet,
baut eine Verbindung auf
mit dem OpenVPN-Server,
allerdings dann bekommst du
eine eigene Netzwerkkarte,
eine virtuelle Netzwerkkarte raus am Ende,
ein Tunnel-Device,
Tab ist noch eins drunter,
wo du kompletten IP-Layer-3-Traffic
drüber tunneln kannst.
Also sprich,
du kannst tatsächlich mit den Endpunkten
auf der anderen Seite reden.
Übers Internet geht das natürlich
selbstverständlich Public
über den schon bestehenden Weg,
weil irgendwie musst du ja zum Ziel kommen
und da drin ist dann aber alles verschlüsselt.
Aber du kannst zum Beispiel
über ein OpenVPN-Tunnel
könntest du beispielsweise
irgendwelche
alten Games spielen,
die
IP unterstützen.
IPX oder irgendwie sowas.
Könntest du theoretisch machen.
Und du kannst sogar noch weiter gehen,
du kannst
anstatt zum Tunnel
kannst du ein Tab-Device machen,
das ist ein Layer-2-OpenVPN,
dann kannst du sogar Broadcasts
über deinen VPN schicken.
Da geht dann sogar so Sachen wie
Autodiscovery von
einer Konsole oder sowas.
Kannst ja dann zwei Playstation 2
anschließen und die sehen sich dann.
Das ist nochmal eine ganze Ebene tiefer,
als wenn du irgendwie
einen Proxy im Browser einträgst.
So, guck mal weiter.
Ups, wo sind wir denn eigentlich?
Die Website.
Also auch durch die VPN-Funktion
bekommt Opera
euren vollständigen Browserverlauf
und sogar die Webseite,
die ihr besucht.
Also ja, gegenüber anderen Anbietern
seid ihr durch den VPN vielleicht
ein bisschen geschützt,
aber halt auch nur bedingt.
Eigentlich auch nicht wirklich.
Das ist ja auch das,
was ich immer bei VPN-Anbietern
kritisiere, die groß da was
von Privatsphäre schreiben oder so.
Eigentlich hast du nicht großartig
was dadurch gewonnen,
weil dein Request muss ja immer noch
zum eigentlichen Zielserver.
So, das heißt,
normalerweise geht das so.
Ihr macht Google auf.
Dann geht das zu eurem Router,
euer Router geht raus
über euer DSL-Modem,
wo kommt das dann wahrscheinlich
im D-6 in Frankfurt raus,
bei irgendeinem Google-Server
oder wo auch immer Google steht
in Frankfurt,
dann bekommst du die Antwort zurück.
Das geht dann public
über das Internet,
eure Packages.
Google kann natürlich lesen,
was in eurer Anfrage drin steht,
weil Google muss ja die Anfrage liefern.
Also zumindest Google kann lesen,
was ihr anfragt, das ist klar.
Und das Einzige,
wenn du über euch,
also sagen wir mal ein VPN,
du gehst über ein VPN,
der Weg zwischen euch
und dem VPN-Server
ist verschlüsselt.
Aber danach nichts mehr
und der Rückweg zurück zum VPN-Server
ist genauso wenig
oder genauso viel verschlüsselt
wie ohne.
Und nachdem eh heutzutage
99 Prozent aller Webseiten
über HTTPS gehen,
ist das kein allzu großer Unterschied
Ja, ein bisschen mehr,
aber letztendlich
die interessanten beteiligten Parteien
können,
also wenn irgendjemand,
also Google wird sich dafür interessieren
für den Traffic,
die müssen den aber auch lesen können,
damit sie euch überhaupt eine Antwort drauf schicken können.
Und wenn ihr jetzt denkt,
ah, aber frag mich nicht,
die China-Chinesen und die Amis
und der BND und was auch immer
können dann aber meinen Traffic nicht angucken,
dann muss man sich erstmal fragen,
okay, was treibt ihr so?
Aber selbst das hilft ja nicht,
weil nach dem Exit
vom VPN-Netzwerk
geht der Traffic ganz normal
durchs Internet zum Ziel-Server
und zurück auch.
Also wirklich großartig schützen
vor irgendwas
tut euch ein VPN nicht.
VPN ist vielleicht sinnvoll,
wenn man eine IP braucht
aus den USA
für Netflix oder so.
Oder wenn man live streamt
und seine IP daheim
nicht leaken möchte
oder sowas aus Versehen.
Da mag das alles irgendwie sinnvoll sein,
aber für Anonymisierungszwecke
eigentlich nicht.
Und ja,
könnte man jetzt sagen,
okay,
es wird dann oft angefühlt,
ja, aber die Anbieter können euch dann
nicht mehr IP tracken.
Nun gut, naja,
doch, können sie schon,
weil ihr habt ja zumindest für die Session
die gleiche Absender-IP
vom VPN, die ändert sich ja nicht
und ihr loggt euch ja oftmals auch ein
bei den Diensten
oder habt schon gesetzte Cookies.
Daran können die euch ja easy,
ohne irgendwelche Fingerprints
oder sonst was erkennen,
ganz ohne Probleme.
Also ob ihr heute von
China-IP kommt
und morgen von der China-Chinesen-VPN-IP.
Das ist dem Anbieter vollkommen egal, ja.
Und da müssen wir noch gar nicht
in Richtung Browser Fingerprinting gehen,
so mit Emojis und Grafikkarten malen
und gucken, wie es aussieht
und was es da nicht alles
für krasse Tricks mittlerweile gibt.
Also nur um das kurz auszuführen,
also eine beliebte Fingerprint-Technologie,
äh, Technologie ist falsch,
eine beliebte Browser Fingerprint-Technik,
also mit Browser Fingerprint ist gemeint,
dass du einem Browser,
einem Benutzer zuordnen kannst.
Relativ eindeutig.
Früher hat man das zum Beispiel so gemacht
mit installierten Schriftarten.
Da hat man so eine Kombination genommen
aus User-Agent und installierte Schriftarten
und alles mögliche,
was man so gefunden hat
und das in Kombination war dann
relativ eindeutig für einen Rechner
beziehungsweise eine Browser-Installation halt,
dementsprechend einen User im Endeffekt.
Mittlerweile sind Browser da schon
ein bisschen besser.
Da kommen Schriftarten raus.
User-Agents gibt es heutzutage
ja auch nicht mehr in dem Sinn.
Es ist alles der gleiche oder meistens
der gleiche User-Agent überall.
Das heißt, es ist, ja, eigentlich,
eigentlich daran kannst du es auch
nicht mehr festmachen.
Deswegen machen die Anbieter heute
solche Sachen wie Fingerprinting
über Emojis zum Beispiel.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch so
der letzte, der letzte Stand ist.
Ja, ich bin nicht im Browser-Fingerprinting-Game,
aber zum Beispiel eine Sache ist,
das sieht die Seite so kacke aus.
Ja, so, euch wird vielleicht auffallen,
hier so,
euch wird vielleicht auffallen,
dass, warum sieht denn die Seite
neuerdings so kacke aus, Alter?
Die hatten doch immer so eine
Schriftarten-History.
Hier, genau, die Seite ist neu.
So, also euch wird vielleicht auffallen,
dass Emojis je nach Plattform
alle ein bisschen unterschiedlich aussehen.
Und dementsprechend machen Hersteller
oder bitte was heißt Hersteller, Anbieter,
die euch tracken wollen,
allerdings die euch nicht tracken können
aufgrund eurer Browser-Settings
oder andere Maßnahmen,
die ihr getroffen habt, versuchen
irgendwie ein Fingerprint anzufertigen.
Also was möglichst, was euren Browser
möglichst einzigartig macht.
Und eines der Tricks in der Vergangenheit war,
ich weiß nicht, ob das noch so
State-of-the-Art ist, was Tracking angeht,
aber ich könnte mir das vorstellen, war,
man zeichnet in ein Canvas
Canvas ist ein HTML-Element,
wo man Pixel selber malen kann,
malt man Emojis rein.
Und daran erkennt man folgendes,
du erkennst schon mal relativ sicher,
welche Plattform der jeweilige User benutzt.
Weil, naja, wenn die Emojis so aussehen,
ist er höchstwahrscheinlich
auf irgendeinem Apple-Gerät.
Sehen die Emojis da aus,
ist er wahrscheinlich auf dem Android.
Sehen die Emojis so aus,
dann ist er wahrscheinlich auf dem Samsung und sowas.
Also ihr erkennt relativ gut,
welche Plattform man verwendet.
Und was ihr damit auch rauskriegt ist,
wenn ihr diesen Test ein paar Mal durchführt,
erkennt ihr sogar,
wie schnell der jeweilige Rechner ist.
Nämlich anhand dessen,
wie schnell er und wie er dieses Emoji malt.
Ihr erkennt zum Beispiel auch an Schriftarten,
welcher Font-Renderer verwendet wird.
Und dementsprechend könnt ihr Rückschlüsse ziehen
aufs Betriebssystem und sowas.
Also an einem popelig,
off-site gerenderten Emoji
kannst du verdammt viel erkennen.
Das heißt,
dass du rein mit JavaScript-Messungen
rausfinden kannst,
welche CPU,
relativ sicher,
welche CPU und welche Grafikkarte
im Rechner verbaut ist.
Dann hast du zumindest schon mal die Information,
welchen Browser benutzt er,
welche Grafikkarte hat er,
welche CPU hat er,
welches Betriebssystem benutzt er.
Da hast du schon mal recht gut Informationen gesammelt
über deinen User,
ohne dass du ihn irgendwie
mit anderen überhaupt tracken,
noch tracken musst
und kannst ihn trotzdem ganz gut zuordnen.
Also man bekommt sowas ganz gut raus,
obwohl man Tracking,
Anti-Tracking-Maßnahmen ergreift.
So.
Ich weiß nicht, wie wir drauf gekommen sind,
aber wir gucken jetzt,
wir gucken jetzt.
Ich gucke mir nochmal die Questions kurz an aus dem Chat.
Ja.
Also wenn du wirklich anonym sein willst,
dann ist Tor wahrscheinlich dein Best-Bet.
Islam ist Fuck
bin ich mir nicht sicher,
wie man das sieht.
Auch gucken, welchen Exit-Node du verwendest.
Nicht unbedingt den von der CIA,
wenn du komische Sachen treibst.
Wobei ich natürlich empfehlen würde,
gar keine komischen Sachen erst im Internet zu treiben.
Lassen sich aus den Cookies
auch nach dem Ablauf des Cookies
die Daten zurückherstellen,
sodass ich meine Passwörter rekonstruieren kann?
Ja.
Du kannst das.
Ähm.
Bei der Webseite
die noch lesen kann nach dem Ablauf.
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Ich weiß nämlich nicht,
ob der Ablauf eine reine,
wie soll ich sagen, Kosmetik-Sache ist.
Da habe ich mich nicht bisher mit beschäftigt.
Eine Kosmetik-Sache ist,
sodass die Webseite sagen kann,
es ist ausgelaufen.
Oder ob der Browser den Cookie,
nachdem er abgelaufen ist,
gar nicht mehr ausliefert.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Du kannst auf jeden Fall,
solange du die Cookies hast,
dann auch nicht.
Genau, wenn du nur deine Session-ID drin hast,
dann nicht.
Doch, hat man.
Habe ich ja gerade versucht zu erklären.
Ja, hat man.
So, wir gucken jetzt das Video fertig.
Ist randvoll mit externen Trackern.
Bing bekommt eure Daten.
Also Microsoft, zu denen Bing einfach gehört.
Google ist mit Google Analytics auch dabei.
Yahoo ist über Y-Image dabei.
Facebook ist auch dabei.
Also eigentlich kann jeder was von eurem Daten abhaben,
auch wenn ihr den Opera VPN benutzt.
Und das bei einem Browser inklusive VPN,
der mit Privacy wirbt.
Dazu kommt übrigens noch,
diese besonderen Add-Ons,
die im Gaming-Browser drin sind,
wie Discord oder Twitch,
sind im Browser.
Ja, die können natürlich alles mitlesen.
Das bedeutet, Opera kann theoretisch alles mitlesen,
was ihr auf diesen Websites tut.
Weitere Gründe, warum ich es nicht verwenden würde.
Das können sie nicht,
wenn ihr diese Websites extern habt.
Aber die große Frage ist,
warum ist dieser Browser so viel schlimmer
als Chrome oder die anderen?
Die Frage, die sich mir eher stellt, ist,
warum hat dieser Browser überhaupt so viele Benutzer?
Ich habe es von Anfang an nicht verstanden,
warum das so viele benutzen.
Wahrscheinlich zieht wirklich die Werbung aus,
weniger RAM, schnellste und Gaming,
ohne dass die Leute, wenn sie es dann benutzen,
sich überlegen,
ja, Moment, ist es denn überhaupt wirklich so?
Die tracken ja auch jede einzelne Website,
die wir besuchen.
Im gruseligen technischen Teil
konnten wir jetzt feststellen,
dass sich Opera ein ziemlich gutes Bild von euch machen kann,
von eurem Profil, wer ihr seid,
welche YouTube-Videos ihr schaut,
welche Musik ihr hört,
auf welche Pornos ihr steht
und welche Dating-Websites ihr besucht.
Jetzt kommt es darauf an,
wem ihr eure Daten geben wollt.
Und das bestimmt die Firma dahinter.
Opera und Opera GX werden entwickelt von Opera Software,
einer nordischen Firma.
Das ist eigentlich nicht gut,
denn in Europa ...
Das war mal so,
... gilt die DSGVO.
Diese Firma und Opera werben übrigens nicht gerade wenig
mit ihrer Geschichte
und dass sie das ja alles schon so lange machen.
Software made in Norway since 1995.
Aber eine Sache verschweigen sie dabei.
Opera war früher ganz vorne dabei
bei den dubiosen Marketing-Konzepten.
Habt ihr euch früher zufällig
auf zwielichtigen Seiten rumgetrieben,
dann habt ihr vielleicht gelegentlich mal Werbung
für Java-Updates
oder Video-Abspiel-Software oder ähnliches bekommen.
Was ihr aber dann tatsächlich bekommen habt,
wenn ihr dieses Java-Update installiert habt,
war Opera,
der sich einfach so als Standardbrowser
in euer System geschrieben hat,
obwohl ihr dachte,
ihr habt ein Java-Update installiert.
Habt ihr über ChipOnline eine Software installiert,
muss man immer höllisch aufpassen,
nicht noch zufällig andere Software zu installieren.
Ja, ChipOnline.
Auch da war sehr häufig Opera dabei.
Das nennt sich Adware
und ist eine Art von unerwünschter Software.
Das ist also nicht gerade eine rühmliche Geschichte,
mit der sie sich da schmücken.
Aber die Firma ist an sich auch eine andere,
als sie vorgibt zu sein.
Opera Software, die norwegische Firma,
von der wir es gerade hatten,
die Opera entwickelt,
gehört zu 100 Prozent der Opera Group.
Und diese Opera Group wiederum
gehört zu 100 Prozent
einem chinesischen Konsortium.
Ein Konsortium ist ein Zusammenschluss
von eigentlich unabhängigen Firmen
um ein gemeinsames Ziel zu verfolgen.
Das heißt, da stecken eben mehrere Firmen dahinter.
Klingt ja auch schon sehr vertrauenserweckend, oder?
Das Golden Brick Silk Road Equity Investment Fund.
Ja, den will ich unbedingt alles schicken.
... ein gemeinsames Ziel zu verfolgen.
Das heißt, da stecken eben mehrere Firmen dahinter.
Die Firma, die aber hauptsächlich drinsteckt,
ist Beijing Kunlun Tech.
Ach, die?
Fun Fact, es ist eben schwer informiert.
Keine Ahnung.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Kunlun.
Aber an der Börse sind sie.
Aber an der Börse.
Sie sind aber eher dafür bekannt,
einfach ausländische Apps aufzukaufen.
Sie haben einige mobile Games,
das musikbasierte Social Network Star Group,
aber vor allem Opera gehören ihnen.
Aber unsere Daten, die wir Opera geben,
sollten ja eigentlich nur
zur norwegischen Opera Software kommen, richtig?
Bestimmt.
Dann haben wir eigentlich nur was von den Profiten,
die aus dem Browser entstehen.
Bestimmt.
Dazu zitiere ich mal übersetzt aus Operas Datenschutzerklärung.
Im Allgemeinen fungieren die anderen Unternehmen der Opera Gruppe,
die Zugang zu personenbezogenen Daten haben können,
als Datenverarbeiter für Opera Norwegen.
Zitat Ende.
Das heißt, innerhalb der Opera Group
können alle anderen Unternehmen auf die Daten zugreifen.
Das heißt, die Daten landen eben doch bei Kunlun Tech.
Und das ist ein Problem.
Einige Beispiele, wieso, mal kurz hier.
Kunlun Tech besaß auch die App Grindr, eine LGBT-Dating-App.
Eine Dating-App ist ...
Grindr.
... ziemlich sensibel.
Sie enthält nämlich Chats, Bilder
und im Fall von Grindr sogar gesundheitliche Daten.
Im April 2018 gab es Berichte darüber ...
Bilder.
Das sind wahrscheinlich zur Hälfte Dickpics, oder?
... dass Grindr den HIV-Status seiner Nutzer an Dritte weitergegeben hat.
Das ist natürlich Dinger.
Allein die Registrierung auf einer solchen Plattform
kann euch in manchen Ländern das Leben kosten.
Sollte Kunlun Tech hier die Informationen
beispielsweise an Länder weitergeben,
in denen Homosexualität illegal ist,
ist das weniger lustig für euch, falls ihr am Fall steht.
Deswegen hat die US-amerikanische Regierung
so lange Druck ausgeübt,
bis Kunlun Tech seine Anteile verkauft hat.
Die USA begründen es mit nationaler Sicherheit.
Und ihr wisst, wie unangenehm die bei dem Thema sind.
Aber auch die Opera Group selbst
ist nicht ganz rein von solchen Problemen.
Opera hat nämlich auch einige Kredit-Apps,
also Apps, wo ihr euch Geld leihen könnt.
Ein Bericht von Hindenburg Research behauptet,
dass einige dieser Kredit-Apps räuberisches Verhalten zeigen
und damit gegen die Google-Playstore-Richtlinien verstoßen.
Die Apps, die infrage gestellt werden,
sind O-Cash und O-Pesa in Kenien,
O-Pay in Nigeria und Cash Bean in Indien.
Räuberisches Verhalten klingt so übel, wie es wirklich ist.
O-Pesa beispielsweise bietet, laut Bericht,
einen Kredit für 91 bis 365 Tage
und 12% maximalem jährlichen Zinssatz.
Zumindest sagen sie das.
Der Bericht sagt, in Wahrheit geht der Kredit 15 Tage
und der jährliche Zins ist bei 438%.
Das heißt nicht rechtzeitig.
Wir werden es übrigens sogar 876%.
Also stellt euch vor, ihr leiht euch 100 Euro,
weil es mal knapp ist und geht davon aus,
dass ihr in einem Jahr 112 Euro zurückzahlen müsst.
In Wahrheit müsst ihr dann aber 876 Euro zurückzahlen,
weil das Marketing euch falsch informiert hat.
Das ist durchaus räuberisches Verhalten.
Deswegen hat Google diese Apps
kurzerhand aus dem App-Store geschmissen.
Klar, in Nigeria, Kenia und Indien
ist jetzt der Käuferschutz nicht so hoch wie bei uns.
Da können sich die Leiher nicht so richtig gegen sowas wehren.
Und was man nie vergessen darf,
auch mit dem neuen Datenschutzgesetz in China
darf der chinesische Staat noch immer zu 100%
auf alle Daten bei Unternehmen zugreifen.
Also auch auf alle Daten von euch bei Kunlun Tech.
An der Stelle erinnere ich noch mal ganz gerne,
dass Minderheiten wie die Uiguren dort verfolgt werden
und unabhängiger Journalismus fast unmöglich ist.
China ist Platz 179 von 180 in der Rangliste der Pressefreiheit.
Wo sind wir?
Wir sind bestimmt auch nicht mehr ganz oben.
Ich habe letztens irgendeine Statistik.
Ich glaube, wir sind auf 10 oder so.
Es gibt zudem ein Social Scoring System,
zu dem ich mal ein Video erstellt habe.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr wollt,
dass ein solcher Staat weiß, was für eine Person ihr seid.
Also, ich fasse noch mal zusammen.
Opera und Opera GX sind Spyware und damit eine Form von Malware.
Opera wird zwar in Norwegen entwickelt,
gehört aber zu 100% einer chinesischen Firma.
Opera erhält Zugriff auf alle eure besuchten Websites.
Der VPN und die Apps machen es eher schlimmer als besser.
Operas Apps wurden schon aus dem Play Store geworfen
wegen räuberischem Verhalten.
Und der chinesische Staat,
der eine Reihe von Menschenrechtsverletzungen
quasi täglich begeht, hat ebenfalls vollständigen Zugriff.
Das heißt für mich, Opera und Opera GX sollte man nicht unterstützen.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Im Gegenteil.
So im Detail war es mir nicht klar,
aber ich wusste, dass ich das nie verwenden will,
weil ich mir das schon gedacht habe.
Ich habe kein Opera mehr verwendet,
seitdem die, also ich hatte davor auch schon nicht mehr,
seitdem die dann die Chinesen verkauft haben.
Opera zu benutzen sei besser als Chrome,
dem kann ich auch nicht mehr helfen.
Chrome ist auch nicht gut,
aber dazu habe ich ja schon einen Browser-Vergleich erstellt.
Um nun eurem Datenschutz ein wenig auf die Sprünge zu helfen,
wir gucken mal kurz rein.
Rangliste der Pressefreiheit.
Was haben wir denn hier so?
Okay, bei uns geht es noch ganz okay.
Den Rest kannst du vergessen, okay.
Also, wen haben wir denn hier?
Land 1, Norwegen, Irland, Dänemark,
die Skandinavier wieder, Litauen, Estland, Portugal.
Wo sind wir? Wir sind hier.
Guck mal, wir sind eine ganze Ecke hinter Norwegen.
Norwegen hat 95 Punkte,
was auch immer das genau ist,
und wir haben nur 81 Punkte.
Und jetzt lasst uns doch mal gucken,
wer hier unten so am Start ist.
Natürlich die Chinakinesen.
Und wer hätte das gedacht?
Auf dem letzten Platz natürlich Nordkorea.
Damit habe ich ehrlich gesagt doch schon gerechnet,
dass es doch unten drunter ist.
Aber guck, gar nicht so viel unten drunter.
Gar nicht so viel unten drunter.
Das sind ja alles hier allemal Länder,
alles zusammen Länder, wo man eigentlich nicht hin will.
Wo ist denn Dubai, wo die ganzen...
Zu was gehört denn Dubai?
Äh, Dubai?
Ja, Emirates.
Da, wo die ganzen Influencer am Start sind,
die sind jetzt auch nicht so geil.
Und wenn die mitkriegen,
dass du bei Grindr registriert bist,
dann finden die das bestimmt auch nicht so toll.
Ich weiß es nicht,
aber ich gehe mal ganz stark davon aus,
dass es schwul oder lesbisch sein dort bestimmt auch verboten ist.
Das ist wahrscheinlich gleich gesteinigt oder sowas.
Also da muss man echt drauf aufpassen.
Das klingt immer so lapidar,
so Datenschutz ist wichtig.
Wir spüren halt selten
die richtig krass negativen Auswirkungen davon.
Da muss ich da wirklich Gedanken drüber machen.
Und man kann einfach auf Opera GX verzichten.
Opera GX kann nichts besser als andere Browser.
Tja...
Ne, jetzt nicht.
Wir fahren das nächste Mal mit ihm nach Berlin.
Chetke, ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Kein Lachs mit Nudeln, heute Nudeln mit Tomatensauce.
RGB 120 FPS Browser.
Das ist halt auch so...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die werben mit 120 FPS,
aber dein Browser wird sich wahrscheinlich
ziemlich stark nach deiner
Display-Refresh-Rate richten.
Und sollte Chrome,
oder sollte Plink,
unter der Haube die ganze Zeuge in Chrome,
das unterstützen,
dann kann das Chrome auch.
Zu Recht, ja.
Klingt wie ein typischer Fall,
warum man in diesem Ranking runtergestuft werden sollte.
Chetke, ich gehe jetzt essen.
Wir sehen uns. Bis denn.
Vielleicht spielen wir heute weiter Ball aus G3
und achten wir drauf.
Bis denn, macht's gut.
See you.